JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH MEETING
OF THE RULES COMMITTEE TO
ORDER. AND BEFORE HI- YES THE
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL I'M
GOING TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
ANNOUNCEMENTS. I TO EXPLAIN THE
PROCESSES THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED
TO CONTINUE OUR CENTRAL WORK
DURING THE PANDEMIC SO FIRST
I'M GOING TO COVER THE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THE FOR
THE DAY. SO IN RESPONSE TO THE
COPA NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS ARE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. BY
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE AT THE
CAPITOL IN SACRAMENTO. WITH ONE
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBER SENATOR
BATES PARTICIPATING IN THE
HEARING REMOTELY. AND WITH THE
USE OF VIDEO CONFERENCE SYSTEM.
IT IS A HOPEFUL SENT- I SEE
SENATOR BATES I THINK IS NOW
JOINED US. ON AND I PROBABLY
DON'T NEED TO RUN THROUGH THIS
BUT I WILL SENATOR BATES I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE MORE FAMILIAR THAN
MOST OF US WITH THE OUR NEW
TECHNOLOGY. BUT A REMINDER TO
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE OR
COMPUTER. BY ANYTIME YOU HAVE A
COMMENT OR QUESTION USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FUNCTION AND I
WILL TRY TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
RAISE THE HAND FUNCTION. WITH
SUPPORT FROM MY AREA BACK UP
STAFF HERE- EACH TIME YOU'RE A
KNOWLEDGE TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK ON YOU
WHEN YOU'RE DONE- I WOULD ALSO
SAY AT SOME POINT SENATOR BATES
I NEED TO ASK YOU AND
POTENTIALLY WHEN YOU WE CALL
THE ROLL FOR QUORUM. MAYBE
WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE IF THERE IS
SOMEONE PUBLICLY WITH YOU IN
THE OFFICE AND LET US KNOW FOR
THE RECORD. AND PUBLIC ACCESS
TO THAT IS WHEN WE CALL THE
ROLL- TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WITH ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER. AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
HOUR ACCESS CODE IS NINE TWO
FOUR ONE. FOUR FIVE EIGHT SO
AGAIN THE NUMBER ON THE SCREEN.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. THE ACCESS
CODE AGAIN IS. NINE TWO FOUR
ONE FOUR FIVE EIGHT. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID FEEDBACK.
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU
WERE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S AN PORT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND UNDERSTANDING.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTED MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STEAM STREAMLINED THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IT IS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAPTOPS FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO THE
NEW ONLINE TOOL SO PLEASE BE
PATIENT SO EVERYONE CAN BE
HEARD. AND FINALLY FOR OUR
STENOGRAPHER KRAINA I WILL ASK
ALL SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES A LIKE TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. SO I BEFORE
WE BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA WE WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM A REMINDER
TO MY COLLEAGUES WILL NEED TO
TURN YOUR MICROPHONES ON FOR
THE ROLL CALL. AND EVERY TIME
WE VOTE SO MADAM SECRETARY LET
ME ASK YOU TO CALL THE ROLL AND
LEAVE TIME FOR SENATOR BATES TO
COMMENT ON WHO IS WITH HER.
BATES YOUR BATES HERO WITH MY
EXECUTIVE ASSISTANT ROOTS
TRACKING. YOU NEED TO BE ON
SCREEN SHE WAS I- BATES HERE
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HERE
LAYERED. LAYERED HERE WILK
PRESIDENT WILL PRESENT ATKINS
HERE ATKINS HERE THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY- I KNOW THE HI.
ARM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED LET ME
TAKE JUST A SECOND AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A COUPLE OF NEW MEMBERS OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE BOB LET ME
WELCOME SENATOR JOHN LAYERED TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE LET ME
WELCOME OUR MAJORITY LEADER
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOUGHT BACK
WITH OBVIOUSLY SENATOR BATES
AND THE VICE CHAIRMAN OF
SENATOR WILK. FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO DISPENSE WITH SOME OF
OUR ITEMS ON THE AGENDA AND I
HAVE TO DO IT I WANTED TO TIME
FOR VARIOUS REASONS LET ME ASK
MY COLLEAGUES IF- WE CAN I CAN
GET A MOTION ON ITEM TWO E.
THROUGH M. A. N. IF YOU NEED TO
SEPARATING OUT LET ME KNOW BUT
CAN WE TAKE A MOTION ON ITEM.
TWO E. THROUGH M. AND THAT IS
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ON WILL MOVE
MOVE YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL LAW I'LL SKIP OVER THE
MAJORITY LEADER AND NOTE THE
MOTION WAS MADE BY THE VICE
CHAIRMAN. I SEE NOTES- REQUEST
TO- ANYTHING OUT OF MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL ON ITEM E. R. TWO E.
THROUGH M. GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. BATES. I IT'S AYE
HERTZBERG AYE BURKE I LAYERED
HI THERE I WILK ALL RIGHT I
ATKINS HI INSIDE FIVE TWO ZERO
THANK YOU THAT PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY I'M GOING TO GO TO
ALL ITEMS THREE BILL REFERRALS
AND AM GOING TO- BEFORE WE TAKE
ACTION ON ITEM THREE REFERRAL
OF BEER BILLS I WOULD NOTE THAT
I AM PULLING SB FIFTY FIVE
STERN FROM THE REFERRAL PACKAGE
TODAY. AND OTHER THAN THAT
WOULD TAKE A MOTION ON ITEM
THREE. BUT MOVED. THANK YOU MR
MAJORITY LEADER OF MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. BATES.
I IT'S AYE HERTZBERG. HI BURKE
FIVE LAYERED ON THIRD AYE WILK
AYE WILK AYE ATKINS ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE FIVE TWO ZERO THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY WE WILL
TAKE- ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS
THE SESSION SCHEDULED FROM
JANUARY THROUGH APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. SO MOVED THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIRMAN CALL THE ROLL.
BATES. I HERTZBERG HI- I
LAYERED ON THERE'D AYE WILK AYE
AYE ATKINS ATKINS HI INSIDE
FIVE TWO ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OUR COLLEAGUES ARE TODAY
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE IS
UNDERTAKING ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
RESPONSIBILITIES AND THAT'S THE
CONFIRMATION OF A GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTMENT TO FILL A VACANT
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICE. THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE ENTIRE SENATE
ROUTINELY DEALS WITH
LEGISLATION THAT AFFECTS THE
LIVES OF FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
TODAY WE HAVE THE DUTY TO
CONSIDER THE APPOINTMENT OF
SOMEONE WHO IF APPROVED BY US
AND BY OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY WILL DIRECTLY
REPRESENT THOSE FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE. IT'S A MOMENT THAT
REQUIRES OUR UTMOST DUE
DILIGENCE. OUR JOB IS MADE
EASIER BY THE FACT THAT
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS APPOINTED
TO SERVICE CALIFORNIA'S NEXT
SECRETARY OF STATE OUR FRIEND
OUR COLLEAGUE. DR SHIRLEY
WEBER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR
SHIRLEY WEBER. I'LL HAVE MORE
TO SAY THROUGHOUT THE
PROCEEDINGS OF COURSE BEFORE
ANYONE PARTICIPATING WHO'S NOT
FAMILIAR WITH DOCTOR WEBER THIS
IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
FROM HER. AND TO HEAR FROM
OTHERS ABOUT HER AND HER
QUALIFICATIONS AND HER VISION
FOR THIS IMPORTANT JOB. UNLIKE
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THE
GOVERNOR CAN FACE. WHEN OFTEN
THERE JUST ISN'T ARE THERE ARE
A LOT OF GOOD OPTIONS TO CHOOSE
FROM THIS APPOINTMENT PROCESS
HAS BEEN ONE FOR GOVERNOR
NEWSOM HAPPEN TO HAVE AN OVER
ABUNDANCE OF GOOD OPTIONS IN
FRONT OF HIM. THERE ARE SO MANY
POTENTIAL APPOINTEES WHO NOT
ONLY HAVE THE EXPERIENCE AND
COMMITMENT TO SUCCEED. BUT HE
WOULD ALSO REFLECT AND ADVANCE
THE DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
ARE STATEWIDE OFFICES. TODAY WE
FOCUS ON THE FUTURE OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE AND
HOW DR SHIRLEY WEBER WOULD HELP
THIS VITAL OFFICE MAXIMIZE
VOTER PARTICIPATION. AND
MAINTAIN ELECTION INTEGRITY
INSURED DISCLOSURE AND
TRANSPARENCY IN CAMPAIGNS AND
LOBBYING. AND ACTIVELY HELP
BUSINESSES WITH THE FORMS AND
FILINGS THEY NEED TO START AND
SUCCEED. ESPECIALLY DURING
THESE TOUGH TIMES AND SO WITH
THAT. LET ME ARE WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR WEBER. I
WANT TO INVITE HER TO MAKE
OPENING COMMENTS INTRODUCED-HERSELF AND HER FAMILY. AND
THEN I WILL GO TO RULES
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
AND DIALOGUE DR WEBER. WELCOME
THANK YOU MADAM OF. PRO TEM AND
I'M HONORED TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY AND I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
FOR- SCHEDULING THIS HEARING ON
THIS SO ON THIS PARTICULAR
RECOMMENDED APPOINTMENT- I WANT
TO INTRODUCE MY FAMILY THAT SHE
WITH ME. MY DAUGHTER AKELA
WEBER DR KILO WEBER IS HERE.
AND MY SON TO KILL WEBER THESE
ARE MY HEART IN MY THROB AND
THEY REPRESENT. MY FAMILY MY
IMMEDIATE COR FAMILY. ALSO WITH
THEM IS MY NEPHEW DON. EDWARD
NASH JUNIOR. AND MY
GRANDDAUGHTER BRIANA BANKS MY
DOCTOR GRANDDAUGHTER DID OF NOW
HEADS AND SO SHE WAS TWO YEARS
OLD. AND SO I HAVE WITH THEM
THEY'RE HERE REPRESENTING THE
NASCO MAN. OF WHICH IS A HUGE
ORGANIZATION A GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE WE ARE OF EACH
OTHER. AND SO I'M SURE THAT
THEY REPRESENT TO MY SIX-
BROTHERS AND SISTERS WHO ARE
PROBABLY WATCHING ONLINE. AND A
HOST OF RELATIVES AND FAMILY
MEMBERS AND FRIENDS TO KEEP
TEXTING ME ABOUT WHAT THEY SEE.
SO I AM HONORED TO BE HERE
TODAY WITH YOU. I WANT TO GIVE
MY THANKS TO THE GOVERNOR- FOR.
TAPPING ME ON THE- IN LOOKING
AT ME IS THE POTENTIAL
REPLACEMENT FOR THE SECRETARY
OF STATE- TO SAY TO YOU THAT IN
SEPTEMBER I HAD NO IDEA THAT
I'D BE SITTING HERE TODAY IS
REALLY AN UNDERSTATEMENT-
BECAUSE I WAS BUSY DOING THE
WORK. OF THE ASSEMBLY. DOING
THE WORK OF THE SEVENTY NINTH
AND MAKING A DIFFERENCE I THINK
FOR THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO I WAS HONORED WHEN HE
ASKED ME TO THINK ABOUT BEING
THE SECRETARY OF STATE. AND I
HAD MY VISITATIONS TO LET YOU
KNOW FOR SURE. BECAUSE I KNOW
IT'S AN AWESOME RESPONSIBILITY.
AT ANY TIME YOU THE FIRST AND I
HADN'T EVEN THOUGHT ABOUT THE
FACT THAT I'D BE THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN TO EVER BE
SECRETARY OF STATE- IN A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY YEARS. AND
THAT I'D BE THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN. AND ONLY TWO
ONE OF TWO WOMEN WHO HAVE
ACTUALLY SERVICE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN. SO THAT'S A TREMENDOUS
RESPONSIBILITY AND A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY. TO BASICALLY STEP
INTO AN AREA. AND TO TRY TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE A DIFFERENT
KIND OF DIFFERENCES OF ALL ON
BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT I'VE BEEN
PROBABLY STEPPING INTO NEW
PLACES AND DIFFERENT PLACES MY
WHOLE LIFE. ANW ARE THE CHILD
OF A SHARECROPPER FROM HOPE
ARKANSAS. IN YOUR FAMILY
PHILLIES IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT BECAUSE SOMEONE IS GOING
TO LYNCH YOUR FATHER AND HE HAS
TO LEAVE HIS FAMILY HIS WIFE
AND SIX CHILDREN. AS HE COMES
TO CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW THAT
YOUR LIFE IS GOING TO BE FEEL
WOULD FIRST THE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES AND TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGES. AND SUCH IS THE
CASE HAVE BEEN MY LIFE TO BE
RAISED IN THE PUEBLOS OF
PROJECTS OF LOS ANGELES. AND
HAVE THE BENEFITS OF SOME GREAT
TEACHERS AND GREAT MENTORS-
THEN TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL AND GO TO UCLA AND HAVE
THE WONDERS OF CALIFORNIA TO
GIVE ME TO ALLOW ME TO ACQUIRE
THREE DEGREES AND ONLY A
HUNDRED A TWELVE HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS. IS AN AMAZING GIFT
THAT MY FATHER COULD NEVER HAVE
JUMPED UP AS HE LEFT HOPE
ARKANSAS. BUT EQUALLY IMPORTANT
IS THAT THE VALUES OF MY FAMILY
THAT HAVE ALWAYS BEEN IN MY IN
MY LIFE. THAT IS IMPORTANT TO
BE. EDUCATED IT'S IMPORTANT BE
SMART. BUT IT'S EQUALLY
IMPORTANT TO KIEV AND TO SERVE.
AND TO BE A CITIZEN AND TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS OF
LOADING. YOU KNOW MY FAMILY OF
MY FATHER NEVER GOT A CHANCE TO
VOTE. WHEN HE WAS IN ARKANSAS
SO HE WAS IN HIS LATE THIRTIES
TWENTY FINALLY REGISTER TO VOTE.
MY GRANDFATHER ON MY FATHER'S
SIDE AND HIS WHAT AND MY
GRANDMOTHER. NEVER VOTED IN
THEIR LIFE. BECAUSE THEY DIED
BEFORE NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE. IS
THAT THEY NEVER HAD A CHANCE TO
EVERGOING TO PULL TO VOTE. AND
MANY OF MY FATHER'S BROTHERS
AND SISTERS WITH THE SAME WAY.
MOST OF THEM WERE ALMOST
ILLITERATE MY FATHER WAS HE
COULD READ A LITTLE BIT BUT NOT
A LOT. BUT HE KNEW THE VALUE OF
WHAT HE HAD MISSED OUT ON. AND
WHY THIS COUNTRY HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO GIVE IT TO HIM AND
HIS FAMILY. AND HOW IMPORTANT
IT WAS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROCESS OF VOTING. SO HE VOTED
EVERY ELECTION. AND WHEN THE
OPPORTUNITY CAME FOR MY MOM TO
WORK ON THE POLE SHE DID. AND
WHEN THE OPPORTUNITY CAME
BECAUSE WE HAD KNOWN NO LIBRARY
NO. REC CENTER IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD TO HOLD A BIG
VOTING PLACE. AND THE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL NOW HAVE
LUNCH FOR BREAKFAST AND LUNCH.
BUT THE POLLING PLACE BECAME
THREE FIFTY ONE WEST FORTY
FIFTH STREET. MY HOME. IN DEPTH
THOUGHT VOTING WAS TOO
IMPORTANT PUT IN THE GARAGE SO
WE MOVED ALL OUR FURNITURE OUT
EVERY ELECTION. IN VOTING TOOK
PLACE IN OUR LIVING ROOM. SO I
GREW UP WITH THE IDEA OF
UNDERSTANDING THE VALUE VOTING.
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO NOT BE
ABLE TO VOTE. I LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY THAT HAD LIMITED
VOTING IN TERMS OF PEOPLE NOT
HAVING FAITH IN THE PROCESS OF
VOTING. NOT BELIEVING THAT IT
WOULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE. AND
DESPITE THAT. MY FATHER MOTHER
BELIEVE SO STRONGLY IN VOTING
THEY ENCOURAGED EVERYONE TO
VOTE. BANKERS ALL OF THE
CHILDREN AND THE GRANDCHILDREN
THEIR NIECES AND NEPHEWS VOTE.
BECAUSE HE REALIZE WHAT LIMIT
HE HAD IN DEFENDING HIS LIFE.
WHEN HE WAS CHALLENGED AT THE
WAY STATION BECAUSE HE WAS THEY
WERE CHEATING HIM OUT OF HIS
ANNUAL MONEY. AND HE FOUGHT
BACK. AND FIGHTING BACK WOULD
MAKE HIS DEATH. AND YET HE
STOOD FIRM BECAUSE HE BELIEVED
IN THAT IT HE KNEW THAT HE
WANTED HIS CHILDREN HAVE A
PLACE WITH IT WAS EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS. SO I
GREW UP WITH THIS KIND OF A
COMMITMENT THAT VOTING IS
IMPORTANT. DIGNITY IS
IMPORTANT. BEING JUST FIGHTING
FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY IS
IMPORTANT. AND I KNEW THAT WHEN
I FINISH TO UCLA. AND GOT MY
FINAL DEGREE AND WAS TEACHING.
THAT I WOULD BE WHAT THEY CALL
A SCHOLAR ACTIVISTS. I'D BE
SOMEONE WHO NOT TO STUDY THE
BOOKS AND WENT INTO MY OWN
COCOON. AND TAUGHT MY CLASSES.
BUT I DO MY BEST TO ELEVATE MY
COMMUNITY. TO EDUCATE THE
COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE THEY HAD
ACCESS TO THOSE THINGS. SO WHEN
I'M CONFRONTED WITH THE ISSUE
OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE. AND
THEN THE RESPONSIBILITY IT HAS.
IT'S ALMOST KIND OF IRONIC THAT
A MAN WHO NEVER WAS ALLOWED TO
VOTE. NOW HAS A DAUGHTER WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THE
VOTES OF FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHAT IS TURN OF EVENTS. WHAT A
CHANGE. IN CALIFORNIA. AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT IS AN
AWESOME RESPONSIBILITY THAT IS
FILLED WITH MANY CHALLENGES AS
WE FACE THE- THE CRISIS TODAY.
WHAT PEOPLE WANT TO DISCREDIT
VOTING WANT TO ALTER VOTING
WANTED MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT
TO VOTE. MAKE IT HARD FOR
PEOPLE TO VOTE. AND WE SAW IN
THE LAST ELECTION SOME
TRAGEDIES THAT WE SAW. BUT WE
ALSO SAW CALIFORNIA RISE TO THE
OCCASION. YOU KNOW THE FACT
THAT MANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN A
PART OF WITH WRITING
LEGISLATION AND I'VE BEEN ON
THE BRETTLER ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE FOR YEARS. WE WILL
LEGISLATION THAT WENT FORTH AND
PEOPLE THOUGHT WELL MAYBE WE'LL
USE IT MAYBE WE WON'T. YOU HAVE
AN OPTION TO DO IT OR NOT TO DO
IF YOU WANTED TO MAIL BALLOTS
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON. SO WHEN
COLE BECAME AND ELECTION.
CALIFORNIA WAS PREPARED. YOU
KNOW WE HAD A GLITCH IS ENOUGH
THINGS THAT FELL APART BUT IN
THE END. WITH THE GENERAL
ELECTION WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT WE
HAD OVER 80% OF OUR PEOPLE
VOTING. UNBELIEVABLE AND I CAN
REMEMBER TIMES WHEN WE WERE
PRAYING FOR FORTY AND FIFTY.
WITH 80% VOTING. WE ALSO HAD TO
SAVE VOTING. WE HAD MULTIPLE
DAYS VOTING AVAILABILITY FOR
FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO VOTE.
COMFORTABLY WITHOUT HAVING TO
BE STRESSED ABOUT VOTING. AND
WE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT IT. AND
I'M HOPING THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN THIS OFFICE THAT WE
WILL TAKE WHAT WE'VE LEARNED.
AND BEGIN TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
MORE OF IT. IN OUR OWN
PRACTICES TO MAKE SURE THAT
VOTING IS X. PASSABLE. THAT WE
REACH EVERY IT NEEDS TO THAT
HAS ABOUT. TO WANTS TO. AND
THAT MY TASK MAKE SURE WE ALL.
HAVE THOSE SAFE PLACE BUT ALSO
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE. AND
THAT EVERY CONCERN IS A MAJOR
CONCERN. BECAUSE WHEN YOU
OVERLOOK THE SMALL THINGS IT IS
THE SMALL THINGS THAT THAT THAT
KNOCKED YOU OUT. THAT HAVE A
TENDENCY TO DESTROY THE GOOD
THINGS THAT WE HAVE. AND
THERE'S NO QUESTION WE'RE IN A
TIME IN OUR HISTORY WE MUST.
FIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
VOTING SYSTEM IS SECURE. THAT
THOSE WHO SHOULD BE VOTING ARE
VOTING. THAT WE MAKE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOLKS THAT
THERE IS NO INTIMIDATION THERE
WAS NO EFFORT TO DESTROY
PEOPLE'S RIGHT TO HAVE THEIR
INPUT. BECAUSE THEIR VOICE IS
IMPORTANT AND I KNOW WHAT IT'S
LIKE WHEN YOUR VICE IS TAKEN
AWAY. AND SO I'M HONORED TO BE
HERE TODAY WITH YOU TO TALK TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I'VE
TALKED WITH MOST OF YOU ABOUT
ELECTIONS YOU KNOW MY PASSION
ABOUT IT. YOU KNOW HOW WE GOING
TO WORK VERY HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THINGS WE'VE INSTITUTED
WILL CONTINUE TO BE THERE. THAT
CYBER SECURITY IS ALWAYS A JOB
THAT NEVER ENDS. AND I'VE
TALKED TO SEVERAL TIMES OUR
CYBER SECURITY FOLKS TO REALIZE
THAT. THIS IS THIS IS SOMETHING
YOU DO EVERY DAY ALL THE TIME
THAT WE HAVE TO STAY ON TOP OF
WITH WORKING. WE HAVE TO MAKE A
TRUE THOUGH VOTING ROLLS ARE
ACCURATE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
AND AND WE'VE SEEN SOME SOME
GROWTH IN SOME AREAS BUT
CLEARLY WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THOSE AREAS THAT HAVE
SOME CHALLENGES WITH THAT. BUT
I'M USUALLY IN INVOLVED IN
CONCERNED ABOUT BUSINESS AND
MAKING SURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
BECAUSE FRIENDLY BIZ AT BUSY.
BUSY FRIENDLY. THAT WE HAVE ALL
FOR FORTUNE FORTUNE WE HAVE
BASICALLY COMPUTERIZED A LOT
ABOUT THINGS BECAUSE OF. THAT
ONLY A PUBLIC OF WHAT WAS IN
PLACE. AND TO BEGIN TO POSSIBLY
ASK BUSINESSES WERE HOW WELL
WE'RE DOING. CAN WE MOVE
FORWARD. WITH THE WHAT KINDS OF
OPPORTUNITIES DO WE HAVE TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIA IS A PLACE
FOR BUSINESS FRIENDLY. AND I.
AND I COME AT THAT NOT SIMPLY
BECAUSE IT MOST FOLKS BECAUSE
THE BOTTOM LINE. AND IT IS IN
MANY WAYS IN THE STATE. BUT
IT'S ALSO THE LIFE OF PEOPLE. I
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE WHEN. MY
DAD DROVE FROM FORTY FIFTH AND
BROADWAY. OVER TO THE CITY OF
COMMERCE. AND SOLVE EVERY YEAR.
THE ELIMINATION OF BUSINESSES.
THAT. WERE IMPORTANT SO FAR
STONE. COULD BE IF. IT'LL BE
STEEL HE WORKED IN LAW AND SAW
THE COMPANY ONE ONE. AND THE
FEAR THAT IT HAD IN THE OF MIND
TO THOSE WHO HARD ALL THEIR
LIVES TO HAVE SOME KIND OF THE
INSECURITY THIS FEAR
UNFORTUNATELY FOR MY DAD HE
RETIRED FROM THIRTY THREE YEARS
AT THE BLISS OF LOCKING IN
MARCH OF NINETEEN. NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE. ALEX AND EMMA HAS
PLANT CLOSE IN JUNE OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE. HE MISSED ABOUT
TWO MONTHS. HE WAS SO HAPPY.
BUT HE FELT VERY BAD ABOUT ALL
THE YOUNG MAN WHO WORKED IN
THAT PLANT. WHO WOULD NOT HAVE
A PLACE ANYMORE. SO I'M VERY
CONSCIOUS OF THE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO BE BUSINESS FRIENDLY WE
NEED TO HAVE GOOD JOBS WE NEED
TO BE PUT TO ENCOURAGE THOSE
WITH THE ACT. AND TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THEM TO BASICALLY DO
BUSINESS AND TO LISTEN TO THEM
AND THEIR CONCERNS WITH REGARDS
TO WHAT WE'RE NOT DOING RIGHT.
IN ORDER TO MAKE IT EASIER
BECAUSE IT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT NOT JUST AS THE
BOTTOM LINE BUT BECAUSE OF THE
LIVES OF THE INDIVIDUALS. AND
AS A KID I KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN SOMEBODY LAID OFF. WITH
SOMEBODY WHEN THERE'S A CUT
BACK. BUT WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
FAMILY WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
SECURITY OF THE FAMILY. SO
WE'LL BE WORKING TO BASICALLY
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE RESPONSIVE
TO THE THOSE ISSUES THAT ARE
CRITICAL. AND LASTLY OF COURSE
AND MOST FOLKS DON'T KNOW I'M
I'M PROBABLY MOST EXCITED ABOUT
THE ARCHIVES OF CALIFORNIA. OF
YOU KNOW THAT IN ITSELF.
JENNIFER AS AN EDUCATOR. FIRES
ME UP WAS DELAYED AS ALSO FIRES
HIM UP. AND AND I SAY THAT
BECAUSE KNOWING WHO YOU ARE IS
CRITICAL. KNOWING YOUR PAST.
PEOPLE KNOWING WHAT CALIFORNIA
WAS ABOUT AND WHAT AND THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE IN THE
THINGS WE OVERCOME. ARE
IMPORTANT. AND THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND. THAT
THE CIVIC NATURE OF OUR
COUNTRY. IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
I'M HOPEFUL THAT IN THIS IN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE. WE
WILL BE ABLE TO HIGHLIGHT OUR
OUR- OUR BECAUSE- THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO TALK ABOUT THE HISTORY
OF CALIFORNIA. BUT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO HELP OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
WOULD CIVIC EDUCATION. OF OUR
TALK TO OUR EDUCATORS ABOUT
THAT TO STRENGTHEN THAT IN THE
STRENGTH OF THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM TO BE PROUD OF BEING A
CALIFORNIA. AND PROUD OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE REALLY UNIQUE.
AND IMPORTANT FOR US. AND THAT
DRIVES US TO THE END TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE A DECISION THAT IS
DIFFERENT WITH REGARDS TO
HUMANITY THAT'S THEIR- SUCH AS
I'M GOING TO CONCLUDE WITH THAT
BY SIMPLY SAYING I AM HONORED
TO BE HERE TODAY- AS I. SAID
WHEN I FIRST WAS TAPPED ON THE
SHOULDER SOMETHING CAN
SECRETARY OF STATE. MMHM I
DON'T KNOW. AND AS I TALK TO
SOME OF MY FRIENDS I SAID WELL.
IT COULD BE A GOOD THING. AND
AS I LOOKED MORE INTO IT I
REALIZED MY GOODNESS. I HAVE
BEEN DOING THIS ALL OF MY LIFE.
AND THIS IS PROBABLY WHERE I
SHOULD BE. BECAUSE THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS NEED FOR PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE STRONGLY IN THIS
COUNTRY. WHO BELIEVE STRONGLY
IN THE RIGHT TO VOTE. WHO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO VOTE. BUT
ALSO UNDERSTANDS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU DON'T VOTE. AND TO
COME OUT OF THAT GENERATION AND
TO SHARE THAT WITH THIS
GENERATION. THAT THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ACT THAT WE
MUST ENGAGE IN. I WOULD
CONSIDER IT AN HONOR TO BE ABLE.
TO DO SO. THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU DR WEBER- IT IS
A GOOD TO HEAR YOUR- IT'S ALSO
GOOD TO SEE YOUR FAMILY. LET ME
START AND GO TO OUR MEMBERS AND
I'M GONNA GO TO SENATOR BATES
FIRST BY. SENATOR BATES I'M
MAKING AN ASSUMPTION YOU ARE I
DIDN'T LOOK FOR YOUR RACE TEN
CM ALREADY NOT FOLLOWING MY
RULES. BUT HI I WANT TO MAKE
SURE- AND START WITH YOU AS WE
TYPICALLY HAVE DONE- REMOTELY
SO CENTER BATES ALTERNATE OVER
TO YOU. THANK YOU. CAN YOU HEAR
CAN YOU HEAR EIGHT. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN SENATOR OKAY
GREAT AND BY THE WAY ARE. THE
SCREEN ON WELL YOU KNOW I MIGHT.
THANK YOU IN ON MY COMPUTER
DOES NOT MAKE RAISE YOUR HAND
ON WAITED SEE THAT. BUT LET ME
BEGIN BY THANKING GRADUALLY
RETURNS DOT. EVERYWHERE
INSURANCE MEDICAL INSURER THE
HOBBIT BRAND OF OR THE COURSE
OF MY- I'M HERE THIS CONGRESS
NAPA. UNDER WARRANTY WONDERFUL
CUP EASTERN THE OTHER DAY ARE
YOU WHILE SHARING ONE HALF WHEN
YOU'RE YOUNGER ALL I KNOW IS
HERE. UNDER EXISTING SCRATCHY
WATER AREAS AND. CONCERNED
ABOUT AND WE SHARE THAT BOTTLE
REALLY ONE OF THE- TOPOLA ABOUT
WHAT YOU. HERE ARE NEVER OF THE
CHAU YES YEARS THAT. THEY ARE
COUNTING BALLOTS THAT WAS A BIG
ISSUE ARE REGARDING THE ABILITY
TO HAVE THAT OVERSIGHT THAT'S
GUARANTEED OUR- YOU KNOW
MEMBERS OF OUR PUBLIC OF BY
ELECTION CURRENT CARD THAT THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE A CLOSE
ENOUGH TO OBSERVE SIGNATURES ON
BALLOTS. THAT'S PRETTY CRITICAL
YEAH WE UNDERSTAND THAT DURING
THE CALL THAT THAT WAS
PROBLEMATIC. SO I'M SECRETARY
VIDEO ACTUALLY RELEASED A NEW
VERSION ELECTION OBSERVATION
RIGHT RESPONSIBILITIES AND GAVE
A LOT OF DISCRETION TO THE
INDIVIDUAL- REGISTERED VOTERS
AND SOME OF THAT WORK IS SUNDAY
BEGINNING BECAUSE IT WAS
REQUIRED TO COME TO DEVELOP.
THAT AREA DON'T THINK A
DESIGNATED AREA WHERE THEY
WOULD THEY WOULD STAND WE'RE
GOING TO BE COMING OUT OF THE
COLD AND YOU ARE. RECALLS
HOPEFULLY AS WE APPROACH THE
SPECIAL ACTIONS THAT CUTTING
OUT THE ANSWER WE ARE THE
ACTUAL TWENTY TWENTY TWO
ELECTIONS LEAD LIKE YOU TO
ADDRESS. HOW YOU WILL ENSURE
THAT WHAT IS NOT REQUIRED TO
BUY THE ELECTION CODE LEARNING
NOT THE OBSERVATIONS LIKE HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO ENSURE ACROSS
THE BOARD BATCH BATCH OR LET'S
SAY THAT VERSION AND I'LL
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES
FOR. ELECTION OBSERVERS THIS
RETURN TO WHAT WAS AND CHAMPION
THAT WENT OFF THE LEGISLATION
THAT CREATED THE RIGHTS TO BE
ARE WE CAN ARE VISUAL ON YOUR-
THE BALLOTS THEMSELVES SO THAT
WE HAVE. AN ANSWER TO THOSE WHO
BELIEVE THAT THAT WAS
INTENTIONALLY SET UP SO THEY
COULDN'T SEE AND VALIDATE-
ACTUAL- YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT
LEADING A LEGITIMATE BALLOTS
BECAUSE IT WAS NOT SO BABY
NATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA I IT
WAS. IN OUR SOME OF. THE ALL OF
THE PRE AND SOME OF THE-
REGISTER. THAT IT WAS A HUGE
ISSUE THE NATION OUR WE'VE GOT
A THEIR- IN TERMS OF ROLLING TO
AND HOW PEOPLE DIALED YET AND
SHE- THE FACT OUR ELECTIONS
THIS NAY. ARE FAIR AND SUNDAY
TO CERTAINLY OUR- AND HONORING
OF THE CONCERTS OF UNITED IS.
THE USE AND STATE CALIFORNIA. I
HEARD THE- CA- IT WOULD IN AND
OUT. BUT- BUT I UNDERSTOOD WHAT
YOU'RE IN OTHER I AM MY SON IS
A MY AXE WILL BE- THOSE THINGS
THAT WE UNDERTOOK BECAUSE OF SO.
JUST AND BE OF COAL IT- WILL
EXIT AS LONG AS WE ARE IN A
PANDEMIC- WHEN THAT. BELIEVE IN
THERE'S NO FOR THAT THEN I'LL
BE WE GO BACK TO THE RULES THAT
WE HAVE- WITH REGARD TO BE BIG
OBSERVERS BEING ABLE TO OBSERVE
THE ELECTION PROCESS AND SO
FORTH AND SO ON SO- BUT I THINK
IT'S LONG AS WHEN COLE WOULD WE
HAVE TO. OBVIOUSLY THOSE ARE
SOME UNUSUAL SITUATIONS THAT WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH AT THE TIME-
SO I SEE NO REASON WHY WE WOULD
RETAIN OF THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE. OF PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO
OBSERVE THAT WE WOULD GO GO
BACK ON OUR OUR COMMITMENT TO
THE- TO THE LAW THAT WAS THERE.
WHAT THEY YOU ARE SURE. BY
THINK THE IT GOT A LITTLE.
DURING THAT TIME KEEPING HEAR
ME MORE CLEARLY. I THINK IT WAS
AN- KIND OF AN OLDER. REACTION
TERMS OF THE ARE THE ONLY TO
OBSERVE AND NOT. BE A- IT. BOB
TRANSMISSION ARE YES. SO I'M
GLAD THAT YOU WILL TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT I KNOW IN OUR
CONVERSATION SHE DID MENTION
THAT YOU WOULD TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AT MOTOR VOTER. WHICH HAS
BEEN A BIG ISSUE FOR ME-
REGARDING THE WAY THE
SCREENSHOTS ARE THERE. FOR ME
ON MANY OF THE PEOPLE AND I
SHARED WITH YOU AN ELDERLY
GENTLEMAN THAT. HELP THROUGH
THAT. WHO REALLY DIDN'T HE
WANTED TO BE ABLE TO SAY. I
DON'T NEED TO RE REGISTER I
REGISTERED OUTSIDE PREFERRED TO
BE REGISTERED AND THERE'S NOT
SOMETHING ON THE SCREEN SHOT.
YES PROVIDED OUT THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES FOR YOU TO BE
ABLE TO SAY. I'M GOOD A CENTURY
SO YOU SAID YOU TAKE A LOOK
BACK. I AND I. DON'T I THINK
LEGISLATION THERE ARE. WAS
REQUIRED INITIALLY BURKE
THROUGH CONVERSATIONS THAT LOOK
LIKE WE CAN. JUST. DO IT WITH A
SIMPLE. CHECK CHANGE BUT THAT'S
BEEN OUT YOU. AND ARE REALLY.
BEEN DOWN ON OUR AND WE CAN. TO
THE POWER. AND PEOPLE REGISTER.
I AM PARTY'S THEY WISH BE READY
AND THOSE WHO. I AM FINE OUT
THAT ARE NOT. TO GO IT SHOULD
FEEL THAT. THEY A LOT WORKS.
THERE SO. I APPRECIATE. YOUR ON
BANDS WE GO FOR. ALSO STILL
THANK YOU AND GOD. WE COVERED
SOME ACTUAL NOT MANY ON THE
LINE BECAUSE I KNOW A LOT MY
CAR. ON THE- HERE ON. WILL HAVE
A NUMBER COVER THE SAME. THAT
MEDIA ACREE SHAPE I YOUR CAN OR
I DURING LARGEST. AND KNOW OUR
JOB. YOUR BACKGROUND IT. YOU
VERY IMPRESSED I'M SO. GOOD
LUCK AND I KNOW THAT ARE IN THE
CENTER OF HEARING YOU WILL DO
EIGHTY ON. A FINE JOB THANK.
THANK YOU CENTER BAY. LET ME
TURN THIS EARLIER. THANK YOU
MAY CHAIR A. N. THANK YOU FOR
OF TO THE PARTS WE'RE
CONSIDERING FOR SPENDING THE
WITH ME- AND WHAT I HAD TO. IS
TO WAS SO OF TO ME IN THE TO
SUBJECTS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT I WANTED TO ASK YOU A FEW
QUESTIONS TO PUT WHAT YOU SAID
ON THE RECORD AND THEN YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT DID ALL FOR A
BIT BECAUSE I REALLY WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT. THE COMMITMENT TO
EVERYBODY VOTING- OF CYBER
SECURITY THE RECOGNITION THAT
THERE'S THE BUSINESS SIDE OF
THE HOUSE AND I WAS POSITIVE
THAT THE ARCHIVES WOULD RISE TO
THE LEVEL THAT YOU WOULD
MENTION THAT IN YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT. THE ED AND SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY YOU ANSWERED MY
QUESTION TO YOU ON THE RECORD
IN A VERY GOOD WAY I FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH YOUR ANSWERS
AND IF AND WHEN YOU ARE
CONFIRMED- I DID BILLS ON THE
ARCHIVES OF THE ASSEMBLY I WILL
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU A
SECRETARY OF STATE THANKS FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO SERVE. AND
THANKS FOR MAKING YOUR PERSONAL
STORY SO IMPORTANT AS A
COMMITMENT TO DEMOCRACY AND
VOTING I THINK THAT REALLY
MAKES A DIFFERENCE HELLO MADAM
CHAIR SHE ANSWERED ALL MY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU CENTER
LATER. THANK YOU- MISTRUST
YEMEN SURE WE CAN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM. SO JUST A COUPLE
THINGS JUST ASIDE WE'RE TAKING
NOTES AND I'M HOPING THIS WAS
AS A COVETING- BUT IN TERMS OF.
THE OFFICE. QUICKLY
ACCOMMODATING CANNONS WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL SO LIKE- I DON'T
KNOW. IN AUGUST A FRIEND OF
MINE SHE'S AN EDUCATOR SHE'S
NOT A POLITICIAN BUT SHE OPENS
UP HER ACCOUNT FOR ELECTION
YEAR AND CLOSE IT DOWN AND SHE
CALLED ME BECAUSE I GOT THIS
PAPERWORK. YOU KNOW AND I'M I'M
GONNA MILLION A MEASURE HOW
LONG IT'S GONNA TAKE IT TAKE IT
I'M A NICE PERSON SHOULD ALWAYS
BRING IT BRING AND DROP OFF MY
HOUSE AND I WILL PERSONALLY
DELIVER IT. ON MONDAY SESSION
ONLY BRINGS HER SHE BRINGS TO
OTHER CANDIDATES WHICH I DIDN'T
ASK FOR AND- SO I DROP HIM OFF
THE FIRST PERSON LIKE IT OUR
LATER TEXT ME SCOTT THANK YOU
SO MUCH THAT'S GREAT AND I WAS
IMPRESSED BECAUSE IT WAS LIKE
NINETY MINUTES. THE OTHER TWO
NEVER EVER. NOTHING AND THEN- I
DROP IT OFF A SECOND TIME
NOTHING THEY HAD SOMEBODY FIVE
FROM SACRAMENTO DROP IN THE BOX
NOTHING AND THEN I DID CALL THE
SECRETARY STATE AND- TO HIS
CREDIT HE HE HOPPED ON THERE.
I'M HOPING IT'S A COVERT THING
WITH PEOPLE WORKING REMOTELY
BUT THAT WAS KIND OF TROUBLING
BECAUSE IT TOOK SIX WEEKS AND-
SO I JUST WANNA LET YOU KNOW
THAT. THE OTHER THING. AND NOT
THAT HAVE NECESSARILY- WAYS TO
FIX IT I DON'T THINK THE
WEBSITES VERY INTUITIVE. AND
SO. WHICH WEBSITE- THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WEBSITE
CRITICALLY ON THE ON THE
POLITICAL STUFF IT'S QUITE
QUITE CONFUSING AT TIMES. I'VE
LEARNED HOW TO NAVIGATE IT BUT
IN AND I'M SURE YOU GOT HIGHER
PRIORITIES BUT I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT. THEN WE I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE THE PLEASURE
OF YOU KNOW ASKING YOU
QUESTIONS AND OUR COLLEAGUES
HAVE. THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
VOTING BUT THEY DON'T ATTACH
YOUR QUESTION SO THIS IS
ACTUALLY A QUESTION FROM. A
COLLEAGUE OF MINE. AND I KNOW
YOU HAVE AN ANSWER FOR SO I'M
JUST GOING TO BE A HIT OUT THE
PARK HOW WOULD YOUR OFFICE
ENCOURAGE SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLDS TO PRE REGISTER AND
VOTE IN ELECTIONS. THAT THEY
MIGHT QUALIFY TO PARTICIPATE IN
PRIOR TO TURNING EIGHTEEN AND
THEN THERE'S A SECOND ONE JUST
pSTATE WERE YOU IN YOUR OFFICE
OFFER SUPPORT TO MR PENALTIES.
AND SCHOOL BOARDS CONSIDERING
PROPOSALS TO INCLUDE YOUNG
PEOPLE. IN LOCAL ELECTIONS.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY INCLUDING
THEM IN ELECTIONS I THINK YOU
KNOW WHAT DIFFERENT PROPOSALS
IN THE PAST TO ALLOW UP. AS LOW
AS SIXTEEN TO VOTE IN SCHOOL
BOARD ELECTIONS THAT'S WHAT I
THINK THAT QUESTION MEANS OKAY
OKAY- WE DO HAVE AS YOU KNOW IN
IN THE SECRETARY OF STATE WE
HAVE AN OUTREACH PROGRAM THAT
WE'VE ALL OF THAT ARE VOTED ON
A COUPLE OF TIMES SO. WITH
REGARDS TO INDIVIDUALS GOING
INTO OUR SCHOOLS WE HAVE A
REGULAR PROGRAM THAT GOES INTO
THE SCHOOLS THAT REGISTERED
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD
AHEAD OF TIME IN ORDER FOR THEM
TO BE ABLE TO VOTE- THERE'S OF
A PROGRAM THAT DOES THAT I'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN IN. IN MY OWN
SCHOOLS WITH US SECRETARY
PADILLA- IT DOES ADD LINCOLN
AND MORSE HIGH SCHOOL WHEN WE
WENT INTO BASICALLY ENCOURAGE
FOLKS TO VOTE SO. THAT'S A PART
OF A PLAN THAT'S A PART OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT WE WILL BE
PASSED TO ENSURE THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE EARLY BEGIN TO VOTE AND
DO HAT- ONE OF THE MEMBERS
ASKED ABOUT THE WHOLE ISSUE OF
THE SEVENTEEN SIXTEEN YEAR OLDS
VOTING. THAT HAS COME UP A
COUPLE TIMES AND OF COURSE MORE
RECENTLY WAS ON THE BALLOT AND
IT WAS VOTED DOWN. SO IF WE'RE
GOING TO DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT
IF YOU NEED A LOT MORE
INFORMATION AND IT MAY BE THE
FACT THAT. IT WAS ON THE BALLOT
IN THERE WASN'T SO MUCH ON
ABOUT THE PEOPLE DON'T PAY
ATTENTION TO IT AND IT JUST GOT
BALLOT FATIGUE CAN DECIDE TO GO
DOWN BECAUSE- IT DIDN'T SEEM
LIKE SOMETHING THAT THEY NEED
TO DO THAT MOMENT. BUT THERE'S
ONGOING CONVERSATION ABOUT IT
AND THERE'S A QUESTION OF
WHETHER NOT THOSE WHO ARE IN
CERTAIN MUNICIPALITIES
ALLOWING. SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLDS TO VOTE IN LIKE
SCHOOL BOARD ELECTIONS VERSUS
OTHER ELECTIONS AND- AND
WHETHER NOT THAT MEETS THE
STANDARD. REGARDS TO THAN THE
OVERALL NATIONAL STANDARDS AND
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
AT SOME POINT. MAYBE LITIGATED
WITH REGARDS TO THE VOTING
RIGHTS AND WITH THE NOT THERE
ARE THESE THAT I KNOW
NATIONALLY TO TRY TO GET SOME
STANDARDS. WHICH I THINK COULD
BE HELPFUL BUT ALSO COULD BE
DANGEROUS AT THE SAME TIME. IF
YOU HAVE SOME STANDARDS THAT
ARE THAT ARE THAT ARE BEING
APPLIED BEYOND. WHAT IS
REQUIRED RIGHT NOW AND SO- SO I
THINK WE'LL STILL HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT BUT I
pTHE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD VOTE.
BEFORE THEIR ELECTION BECAUSE
THEY FELT THEY DIDN'T WANT THEM
TO BE ABLE TO. ENTER INTO IT
UNTIL THEY WERE EATING. YEAH WE
HAVE A LOT OF A- CAN. ISSUES
WITH. A CAL. YOUR KNOW. AT ONE
POINT SAY YOU CAN. SMOKE IT YOU
IN THE- TWENTIES. WITH YOU CAN
VOTE. IF SEVEN. IF PEOPLE SO IF.
CAN YOU SIXTEEN YOU'RE- CAN
MAKE THE DECISIONS WHICH CAN
MAKE THE DECISIONS ABOUT. BUT
SMOKING OR SOMETHING. AND SO WE
HAVE A LOT OF THAT GOING ON AND
SO. AT SOME POINT THERE ARE WE
HAVE WE HAVE A CONVERSATION
ALMOST EVERY UNIT IN THE
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. AND SOME
GETS THROUGH SOME DOES NOT-
BUT- I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER RULES
ARE WITH REGARDS WITH THAT WE
OF THAT THEY'RE ENFORCED. AND
THAT WE SUPPORT THEM. GREAT-
CAME AGAIN NOT NOT MY QUESTION
A COLLEAGUE'S QUESTION BUT
THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING THAT.
SO I WAS SOMEBODY THAT ACTUALLY
IN A I WAS IN THE MINORITY IN
MY **** IS I'VE- I'VE VOTED TO
DO ALL MAIL IN BALLOTS- WITH
THE KNOWLEDGE OF HER FOR IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC RIGHT ONE.
INTO ABOUT 70% OF OUR VOTERS
ALREADY GO ABSENTEE BALLOTS SO
I FELT LIKE WE WERE IN A PRETTY
GOOD POSITION. TO DO THAT AND I
KNOW THAT FOR. CHALLENGES IN
PENNSYLVANIA AND OTHER PLACES
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
EXPERIENCE WE HAVE. THE ONE
THING I WAS CONCERNED ABOUT-
JUST FROM ALL THE CALLS A GUY.
IS CLEANING UP THE VOTER ROLLS.
BECAUSE ALL THESE BALLOTS ARE
FLOODING INCLUDING MY HOUSE
THERE'S BALLOTS YOU CAME TO MY
HOUSE THERE FOR MY DAUGHTER
AND- AND- HER HUSBAND THAT.
LIVE LIVE OUT OF STATE AND- SO
AND I KNOW WE HAVE PARTICULAR
PROBLEMS IN IN L. A. COUNTY
WHAT WHAT CAN YOU DO TO TAKE TO
CLEAN THAT UP. SO THERE IS MORE
CONFIDENCE. YOU KNOW IN IN THE
ELECTION PROCESS BECAUSE- IF WE
IF WE DON'T GET ELECTIONS RIGHT
THEN YOU KNOW WE HAVE NO
CREDIBILITY IN IN THE WAY WE
GOVERN SO QUESTION YEAH I KNOW
THAT THERE'S A THERE'S AN ISSUE
IN LA MY UNDERSTANDING WHAT I
TALK TO STAFF ABOUT IT IN AND
WE'LL LOOK INTO IT IS THAT IT'S
GOTTEN BETTER- IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO SCRUB THE ROLE SO
MAKING SURE THAT THE- THAT THE
REGISTER VOTERS IS DIRECTLY
CONNECTED TO THE BILL OF
STATISTICS AND SO WE- SO WE
HAVE SOME IDEA OF WHO'S DYING
AND WAS LIVING- BUT LIKE SO
MANY THINGS I MEAN IF YOU. IF
YOU HAVE A RELATIVE A FRIEND
WHO LIVES OUT OF STATE I MEAN.
WHO KNOWS THEY THEY LAUGH I
MEAN OTHER THAN. THE PERSON WHO
LEFT IN A DILIGENT ABOUT. BUT
THEMSELVES BASICALLY LETTING US
KNOW THEY MOVE OR THE FAMILY
MEMBERS OR WHATEVER SO. I KNOW
THERE'S AN EFFORT TO COSTLY DO
THAT AND MAKE SURE WAS
SCRUBBING THE ROLES AND- AND IT
IS AGAINST THE- IT IS ILLEGAL
TO VOTE FOR SOMEBODY ELSE SO WE
DO HAVE THAT AS AS AN AS AN
OPTION. BUT BUT I KNOW THAT THE
L. A. IS WORKING ON IT AND IN
THE SAME WAY I HEAR STORY. AS
YESTERDAY SOMEONE SAID WELL
SOMEBODY GOTTA PUTS A BALLOT
FOR SOMEONE WHO NO LONGER IS
ALIVE. AND THEN I GOT A NOTICE
FROM SOMEONE ELSE'S YEAH BUT MY
UNCLE DIED AND I GOT A NOTICE
IMMEDIATELY FROM THE- SAYING
THAT HE HAD BEEN TAKEN OFF THE
ROLE SO. WE'VE GOT TO CLEAN IT
UP A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
OBVIOUSLY AND WITH THAT AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE- WHEN
YOU HEAR THE STORIES OF- EVEN
IF THEY'RE SMALL YOU KNOW YOU
THINK YOU DO THAT YOU DON'T
SEVENTY MILLION BOOKS. AND YOU
HEAR ONE PERSON TELL YOU THAT A
DEAD PERSON VOTED. I MEAN YOU
KNOW. BEEN AT SEVENTEEN BE.
ALMOST BECOMES INSIGNIFICANT TO
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE WHO ONE WHO
THINK THAT THE SYSTEM'S FAULT
SO WE HAVE TO. PAY ATTENTION TO
IT WE CAN'T IGNORE IT- BUT
ALSO- AND I DON'T MISS IT PUT
IT IN PERSPECTIVE SALE THAT'S
ONLY ONE OUT OF SEVENTY
MILLION. BUT WE NEED TO FIND
OUT WHAT AT ONE. THAT WAS THE
YEAR. AND THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
ME RIGHT NOW PRETTY SHAPE THAT
AND AGAIN I DON'T KNOW HOW
SYSTEMIC IT IS I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY MORE PRONOUNCED IN L.
A. COUNTY- AUGUST KRANTI MY PIE
WHY'D THEY WERE SUED. AND SUED
SUCCESSFULLY- SO. NOTHING THING
I WANT TO ASK ABOUT THINK
THERE'S- WILL COME- IT MIGHT.
SO THERE'S- TALKING. THAT I'D
BE. IN SO- BECAUSE I WANT TALK
ABOUT THE THIRTY. MILLION IN.
SOURCE CONTRACT FOR VOTER
EDUCATION. SO WHEN APPROPRIATE
I WOULD LIKE TO. GET ALL. WORK
PRODUCT RELATED TO THE CONTRACT.
I AM INTERESTED IN INVOICES
MEMOS AND DIRECTIONS GIVEN ON
DIGITAL ADVERTISING AND DIRECT
MAIL TARGETING. AND THE REASON
WHY I WANT THAT TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU IS I WENT BACK AND
LOOKED AFTER THE ELECTION AND
THAT PARTICULAR FIRM ALSO WAS
ENGAGE IN FIVE CAMPAIGNS AND
THE FIVE CAMPING OUT OF ALL THE
CAMPAIGNS IN CALIFORNIA. FOUR
OF THEM WERE TARGETED
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS AND ONE WAS
A TARGETED SENATE C. SO I'M
PRAYING THAT WE WERE NOT
LEVERAGING TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
ASSIST- SINCE GET KANSEN THAT'S
NOT ON YOU BUT I WOULD YOU I
JUST LIKE TO SEE THAT. BECAUSE
I'D LIKE TO HAVE. YOU KNOW SOME
COMFORT THAT IN FACT THAT DID
NOT OCCUR. BUT INSTEAD IS A BET
MAKE THAT REQUEST TO MY OFFICE
I'LL BE DOING WRITING YEAH
ABSOLUTELY I DON'T REMEMBER
FROM SITTING HERE I KNOW I
TOTALLY GET IT. SO SO YOU DO
THAT YOU HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE CONTRACT SO I WANT TO
KNOW IF YOU BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS EXCLUSIVE
AUTHORITY. TO APPROPRIATE FUNDS
TO SECRETARY STATE FOR ANY
PROGRAM WITHIN THE SECRETARY'S
AUTHORITY. DO WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO. DO WE HAVE
AUTHORITY TO DO IT YES OKAY
THROUGH OUR BUDGET PROCESS YES
OKAY DO YOU BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS EXCLUSIVE
AUTHORITY TO IDENTIFY THE
SPECIFIC AMOUNT TO BE
APPROPRIATED FOR THAT PROGRAM.
AND THAT YOU WILL HAVE NO
AUTHORITY TO SIMPLY CHOOSE THE
AMOUNT YOU THINK IS APPROPRIATE
TO SPEND. SO ONCE WE'VE AFTER
WE'VE AUTHORIZED IT DO YOU HAVE
TO STAY WITHIN THE CONFINES OF
THAT ANDREAS A WITHIN THE
CONFINES OF THE APPLICATION
SURE RIGHT. YOU BELIEVE- THE
JOB OF THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
TO CONFIRM THAT BEFORE ANY
PAYMENT IS MADE FROM THE STATE
GENERAL FUND THAT THERE MUST BE
A VALID APPROPRIATION APPROVED
BY THE LEGISLATURE. I ASSUME
THE SECOND THE CONTROLLER WILL
YES OKAY THE RESPECTED PENA THE
CONTROLLER IN THAT REGARD. IT'S
RESPECT WHAT. DO YOU RESPECT
THE OPINION OF THE CONTROLLER
IN THAT REGARD IN TERMS OF IT
THE EXPENDITURES. IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOCATE
RESOURCES RIGHT AND IT'S A
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
CONTROLLER TO DISBURSE THOSE
RESOURCES BASED UPON THE- THE
LEGISLATION WITH REGARDS TO
WHAT THE COMMITTEES THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE PRESENTS- DO THEY
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO THEN
DECIDE THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO
DO IT IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE- I
DON'T KNOW. I DON'T HAVE AN
OPINION ABOUT IT I THINK YOUR
ANSWER WAS YES WHICH IS WHAT
I'M OKAY OR SEMI PRO RIGHT
THAT'S GOOD. SO IF THE
CONTROLLER SAYS IT THERE'S NO
ABOUT APPROPRIATION FOR
PROGRAMS TO U. S. SECRETARY
WOULD LIKE TO INSTITUTE WOULD
YOU BUY BY HER DECISION. AGAIN
IT'S- BOB IF NOT OUTRIGHT BY ME
DOING WHAT I KNOW ABOUT ALL OF
THIS BECAUSE IF YOU KEEP
REMINDING YOU KNOW YOU'RE DOING
THIS TORRENT GREAT I'M JUST
GOING THROUGH I'M JUST I'M JUST
TRYING TO FGURE OUT WHERE
WE'RE GOING- I'M JUST GOING TO
WORK ON GETTING YOU OUR RECORD
THAT YEAR I HAD THAT I GATHER
THAT I GATHER THAT IS
AUTHORIZED BY THE LEGISLATURE I
GET I GATHER THAT AND YOU KNOW
YOU SAID YES ENOUGH TIMES TO BE
THAT I'M SAYS I AM SATISFIED
WITH THE ANSWER BUT OKAY SOUNDS
GOOD WE'RE NOW WE'RE WE'RE
GOOD. SO AGAIN HE TOOK A
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND AGED AGAIN
EVERY TIME I HEAR YOUR STORY
BECAUSE IT'S AN INCREDIBLE
STORY I- I ALWAYS ENJOY IT AND-
I'M SURE YOU WILL BE IN A VERY
EFFECTIVE SECRETARY. ST THE-
YOUR APPROVAL THANKS. AWARENESS
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIRMAN I
THIS MAJORITY LEADER. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH JIM MANAGE MEDICAL
TERM. YOU KNOW I IN BY YOU'RE
DIZZY FOR OFFER I THINK HAS ITS-
PASTA. AND- CERTAINLY WE'VE
SEEN THE VOTING PARTICIPATION
THIS LAST TIME GOING BACK TO
THE DAYS OF TRUMAN JUST
EXCITING EXCITING AT EVERY
LEVEL OF ALL OF US TO BELIEVE
IN OUR HEART AND DEMOCRACY IT'S
FANTASTIC. IT IS SO MANY OTHER
ELEMENTS AND JUST AS WE TALKED
ABOUT I WAS A NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT I CARE DEEPLY IS JOINT
AUTHOR OF FOUR FIFTY ON THE
VOTE CENTER. THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WE PUT INTO DUE
TO OF MACHINES- BACK WHEN AL
GORE WAS RUNNING FOR OFFICE AND
WE GET READY WE FOUND 53% OF
THE MACHINES WRITTEN CALIFORNIA
OR HANGING CHADS. SO I SHARE
YOUR DUES YES AND FOR THE WORK
OF THIS OFFICE I WANT TO JUST
RAISE. A COUPLE OF ISSUES TO
PIGGY BACK WITH MY COLLEAGUES
TALKED. ABOUT FIRST ON THE
CAMPAIGN FINANCE ISSUE. RIGHT
JUST SHARE TERMS- WHETHER. THE
SYSTEM IS CURRENTLY INTUITIVE
WE- BUSINESS LEGISLATURE AND-
APPROPRIATED MONEY SOME YEARS
AGO TO UPDATE CAL ACCESS. WHICH
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
IT MORE INTUITIVE- THERE'S BEEN
MANY MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
SPENT. AND I AND I MARRY THAT
WITH THE ISSUE THAT WAS
MENTIONED ABOUT BUSINESS. YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS FOUR POINT
ONE SMALL BUSINESSES A TWO
THIRDS OF ALL JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA COME FROM SMALL
BUSINESSES NINETY NINE POINT
EIGHT PERCENT. OF ALL
BUSINESSES SMALL BUSINESSES AND
THOSE INTERFACE WITH YOUR
OFFICE. AND WHETHER THERE LLCS
ARE ELLO PEAS OR SMOKES S.
TOPSHOP DRESS CORPORATIONS OR
WHATEVER THEY ARE. I JUST MARRY
THAT WITH THE SAME NOTION ABOUT
THE INTUITIVE SENSE OF THE
POLITICAL SIDE OF CAL ACCESS.
WITH THE POLITICAL SIDE WITH
THE BUSINESS SIDE TO MAKE.
EVERY DAY YOU KNOW MAKE IT MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO FOLKS WHO
GOVERNMENT'S INTIMIDATING THE
PEOPLE IT SCARED TO GO ON THESE
THINGS IS SOMETIMES OF ALL
THESE FORMS AND ALL THE STUFF
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO. ALL I
SUGGEST IS AS YOU. WE
UNDERSTAND THE CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS WE UNDERSTAND THAT WE
IS. CARE DEEPLY ABOUT ACCESS TO
THIS INFORMATION JUST IN EVERY
RESPECT BECAUSE YOU'RE SO MUCH.
INTERFACING WITH THE PUBLIC NOT
JUST IN THE ELECTION SIDE BUT
BUSINESS SIDE HE JUST MAKE IT
IS EASILY ACCESSIBLE ISN'T TO
THEIR FEARS FOR FOLKS AS
POSSIBLE. YOU KNOW I REMEMBER
SOME YEARS AGO AND WE DID- CAL
WORKS THE APPLICATION WAS FORTY
THREE PAGES AND WE GOT A
HUNDRED FIFTY. FOLKS TO SIGN UP
WE ULTIMATELY GOT IT DOWN TO A
POSTCARD AND MADE THE SYSTEM
WORK SO. JUST TO THE EXTENT I
SURE THAT THINKING THE ISSUES
THAT WERE SPOTTED BY. BY MY
COLLEAGUES AND I ALSO IN TH<c.cyan></c>
ASKED ECCLES. ENDORSE THE- THE
ISSUE ABOUT ARCHIVE SAYS A
CALIFORNIA STORY AND SOMEONE
WHO WENT TO A MODERN NEVER MADE
IT THROUGH LIKE YOU DID. IN THE
PHD PROGRAM I LOVE CALIFORNIA
HISTORY I THINK IT'S A
FANTASTIC. ADDITION BECAUSE OF
YOUR- YOUR ABILITY AND YOUR
SKILL IN YOUR INTEREST TO BE
ABLE TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUES OF
THE ARCHIVES AND I JUST WANT TO
COME CLEAN. WITH YOUR FAMILY
HERE TO SAY THAT WHEN I SPOKE
TO YOU I SET UP. AT THE OUTSET
OF OUR INTERVIEW I DID NOT WANT
TO VOTE FOR YOU TO BE.
SECRETARY OF STATE AND THAT WAS
NOT BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THAT
YOUR EXCELLENT AND BRILLIANT
WOULD DO A GREAT JOB. I JUST
WANT TO KEEP WORKING WITH YET.
IN THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
BUT I IT THROUGH THE ETHNICALLY
SUPPORTED EXCITED THAT YOU
CHOSE TO UNDERTAKE THIS
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITY YOUR
MAGNIFICENT LIFE. AND I AM
LOOKING FORWARD TO CALLING YOU
MADAM SECRETARY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MR BURKE YEAH
IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH YOU AND I CAN'T BELIEVE
IT'S BEEN SIX YEARS. I CANNOT
BELIEVE IT. YEAH FOR MR
MAJORITY LEADER THANK YOU I.
TWO WAS TO YOU DOCTOR WEBER I
AM SURE THAT HE WILL FIND A WAY
TO WORK WITH YOU. MAKE NO
MISTAKE AND THEN HE TYPICALLY
DOES IT LATE AT NIGHT SO I'M
FOR WARNING YOU NOW- I DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I THINK I
KNOW WHO YOU ARE AND I THINK I
KNOW WHAT DRIVES YOU- BUT I AM
GONNA GO TO THE PUBLIC AND I
WILL HAVE COMMENTS. LATER AFTER
WE HEAR FROM THE PUBLIC. SO-
WILL MOVE TO- FOLKS WHO WANTED
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT WE ARE IN
ROOM FOUR TWO OH THREE. SO
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
WITNESSES HERE. TO THE
WITNESSES I WANT TO REMIND YOU
TO ENSURE SOCIAL DISTANCING SO
DO NOT FORM A LINE OVER HERE.
ONLY ONE PERSON AT A TIME AT
THE MICROPHONE. AND ONCE A
WITNESS CONCLUDES THE NEXT
WITNESS MAY COME FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE. AND SO I WILL GO
AHEAD AND START THAT PROCESS WE
CAN REMIND SPEAKERS TO SPEAK
CLEARLY AND SLOWLY FOR OUR
STENOGRAPHER SO. IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY THE
MICROPHONE IS OVER HERE. I WILL
GIVE IT A MINUTE IN SUPPORT. I
AM SURE THAT ALL OF YOUR FAMILY
MEMBERS YOUR SUPPORT YOU- SO
LET THEM WAVE THEIR HANDS WILL
TAKE THAT IS A LIST OF- YOU
WERE HERE IN SUPPORT. I'M GOING
TO MOVE FROM OF THIS ROOM WE
HAVE A BACKUP ROOM- BASED ON
HOW WE ARE CONDUCTING OUR
HEARINGS AND SOCIAL DISTANCING.
I'M GOING TO MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. AND SEE IF WE HAVE
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO STEP UP TO
THE MICROPHONE. OKAY SEEING NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE THAT IS
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE I'M
GOING TO MOVE IN SUPPORT TO THE
TELECONFERENCE- WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS SO I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
MODERATOR STANDING BY WHO WILL
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF DR WEBBER-
AND TO THE WITNESSES I'M GONNA
REMIND YOU SPEAK OUT WHEN YOU
SPEAK TO PROVIDE YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND THE
POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT.
AND AGAIN ON BEHALF OF OUR
STENOGRAPHER PLEASE SPEAK
SLOWLY SO MADAM- I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S A MATTER OF- MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES INTRODUCED HERSELF AND WE
WILL MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. PLEASE ALLOW MOMENT WE
DO HAVE A FEW THAT ARE KILLING
UP. OKAY MISTER MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE PEOPLE STANDING BY. YES
I'M JUST WAITING A MOMENT TO
BEST ALIGN TO BE RELEASED SO I
CAN INTRODUCE THEM ONE MOMENT
PLEASE OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWELVE LINE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN ANYMORE. YES MY NAME IS
JOHN LOCAL. WE ARE BOB CAPITAL
BURKE THIRTY FIVE YEAH BUT WITH
THE IN ALL OF THE CLIENTS BOB
LAWN. FOR YES WE CAN STRONG OF
THE NOMINATION OF BARDOCK WELL-
THIS IS YOUR- OUT. APPOINT THE
VERY VERY. WHAT THAT-
PROFITABLE MADE THE DECISION
ABOUT THE WELL AS I'M THE
FELLOW. OF THE STATE COULD NOT
THE FRANCHISE. AND THE PROPOSAL
WITH YOUR WELL SHE WILL BE LOS
OUT- PROPONENTS- THE AND DRIVES
I. WITH YOUR- WHAT WE WONDER
I'M- THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M VERY
PROUD THIS IN SUPPORT OF DOUG
WEBER. THANK YOU MISTER LEVEL
MISTER MODERATE NEXT SPEAKER.
THANK YOU AS OUR MAKE UP A
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE'LL GO LINE ALLOW LINE YOUR
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
MY MURPHY. AM ADEPT DISTRICT
FOR L. A. COUNTY AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF BLACK LAWYERS.
IT IS WITH GREAT ENTHUSIASM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
LAWYERS RECOMMENDED THE
CONFIRMATION OF TRAILBLAZER
ASSEMBLY WOMAN DOCTOR SHIRLEY
WEBER. AS CALIFORNIA SECRETARY
OF STATE TO REPLACE THE
HONORABLE ALYCIA AFTER HIS
APPOINTMENT AS UNITED STATES
SENATOR FROM THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TABLE REPRESENTS
OVER SIX THOUSAND AFRICAN
AMERICAN ATTORNEYS JUDGES LAW
PROFESSORS AND LAW STUDENTS.
ABLE CONTINUES ITS MISSION TO
PROMOTE REFORM AND A LOT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OBJECTED. AS WE
CONTINUE OUR QUEST FOR EQUALITY
AND EMPOWERMENT. IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE DEADLY RIOT AT
THE UNITED STATES. AT ALL ON
JANUARY SIXTH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE. EXTEND ON FALSE
ALLEGATIONS OF VOTING
IRREGULARITIES ACROSS THE
NATION. GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM'S
APPOINTMENT OF DR WEBER COMES
AT A CRITICAL TIME IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY. CALIFORNIA
NEEDS SOMEONE WITH DR WEBBER
DEDICATION TO SOCIAL JUSTICE
AND COMMITMENT. TO PROMOTING
AND PRESERVING DEMOCRACY. SHE
WILL ENSURE THAT ALL CITIZENS
ARE ABLE TO EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHT TO VOTE. AND WITH HER
EXTENSIVE BACKGROUND IN
EDUCATION AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ADVOCACY WILL PROMOTE
INITIATIVES ON BETTER EDUCATION
AND ELECTION PROTECTION. WE
SALUTE DR WEBER'S LEADERSHIP
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE AS THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS. AND PROFESSOR EMERITA
AFRICAN EXPEDIA'S I SEE ANY OF
THE STATE UNIVERSITY. SHE ALSO
FOUNDED THE BLACK WOMEN'S
INITIATIVE OF DEVELOPMENT
INSTITUTE OF DEVELOPMENT I'M
SORRY WHICH TRAINS WOMEN HOW TO
RUN FOR PUBLIC OFFICE AND
ADVOCATES. DIEM PORTENTS
ABILITY. CABLE RECOGNIZED DR
WEBER OUTSTANDING
ACCOMPLISHMENTS BY HONORING HER
WITH THE LEGISLATOR OF THE YEAR
AWARD. AT OUR ANNUAL
LEGISLATIVE. DAY IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. WHEN I
STARTED IS MY IT YOU HAVE A
RIGHT TO TIRED BUT YOU DO HAVE
A RIGHT TO UP. DR WEBER HAS
BEEN TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR ALL.
AND A MENTOR PER MEMBER THAT HE
WHO SEE GUIDING AND SUPPORT SHE
EMULATES THE BRAND OF
LEADERSHIP WE ALL ASPIRE TO.
THEREFORE ABLE STRONGLY
RECOMMEND HER CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER. WE HAVE
NO MORE IN SECU FOR IN FAVOR AT
THIS TIME. OKAY I THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
IN A FEW MOMENTS. HAVING HEARD
FROM THE SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FROM ON ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION SO WILL
BEGIN HERE IN ROOM FOUR TWO OH
THREE. AGAIN ONE PERSON AT A
TIME ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY SEEING NO ONE
STEPPED FORWARD LET ME. FOR THE
PURPOSES OF PROCESS LET ME MOVE
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. AND SEE IF
THERE IS ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
SEEING NO ONE APPROACH- THE
DYESS LET ME COME BACK TO YOU
MISTER MODERATOR. AND MOVED TO
WITNESSES WHO ARE WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE IN
OPPOSITION. THIS IS ON THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION YOU MAKE
YOU UP AT THIS TIME BY PRESSING
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AND THERE IS NO ONE
SHOWING UP IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR TOM OKAY. WE WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES ANYTHING
FURTHER. MOTION FROM THE
MAJORITY LEADER THANK YOU- IDEA
I DIDN'T HAVE QUESTIONS- BUT I
DID WANT TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT INCREDIBLE
HONOR IT IS TO- HAVE YOU BEFORE
US TODAY DR WEBER. YOU KNOW
WHEN I- MOVED TO SAN DIEGO I
WAS TWENTY THREE YEARS OLD. AND
I HAD NO IDEA WHAT THE FUTURE
WOULD HOLD I MET DR WEBER WHEN
I WAS TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD.
WHEN SHE WAS TWENTY THREE YEARS
OLD- SHIRLEY WEBER WAS ALREADY
HELPING STUDENTS WITH THEIR
FUTURES. AS A PROFESSOR AT SAN
DIEGO STATE AND- I SAW HER OUR
PATHS CROSSED WHEN SHE SPOKE AS
A PRESIDENT OF THE SCHOOL
BOARD. AT A LOCAL OUR LUNCHEON
IN SUPPORT OF YOUNG WOMEN
PARTICIPATING IN OUR COMMUNITY.
I HAVE BEEN CONTINUALLY
IMPRESSED BY DR WEBER'S
COMMITMENT TO EDUCATION. AND TO
SO MANY OTHER ISSUES AFFECTING
OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR CITY
WHERE WE CAME TO KNOW EACH
OTHER OF SAN DIEGO AND OF
COURSE IN THE LARGER SOCIETY.
SO DR WEBER'S DETERMINATION WAS
ON MY MIND WHEN I BECAME
SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY. I
BELIEVE THE ANNUAL STATE BUDGET
IS OUR MOST IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITY AS A
LEGISLATORS. SO I SPEAKER I
NEEDED SOMEONE SPECIAL. TO TAKE
ON THE ENORMOUS JOB OF BUDGET
CHAIR A BUDGET CHAIR WHO COULD
HELP CALIFORNIANS RECOVER FROM
THE GREAT RECESSION. AND HE
WOULD CONTINUE THE PATH OF
RESPONSIBLE LEADERSHIP IN TERMS
OF BUILDING RESERVES. AT THE
TIME DR WEBER HAD SAID THE
BUDGET IS A MORAL DOCUMENT.
IT'S A STATEMENT OF OUR VALUES
AND WHERE WE INVEST OUR
RESOURCES REFLECTS WHAT WE
VALUE AS A SOCIETY. AND WHAT
OUTCOMES WE EXPECT IN THE LIVES
OF THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
HER STRONG SENSE OF MORALITY
AND PUBLIC SERVICES ONLY ONE
REASON DR WEBBER WAS THE RIGHT
PERSON FOR THIS JOB. AND
SPEAKING OF COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE AS SHE DID
AND HER COMMENTS. THAT SHE WAS
ALSO THE RIGHT PERSON FOR THE
JOB WHEN MY SUCCESSOR AS
SPEAKER SPEAKER RENDON. PAINTER
TO CHEER THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE WHERE SHE FOCUSED HER
LEADERSHIP ON MANY OF THE KEY
ISSUES OVERSEEN. BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. TWO YEARS
AGO AT THE END OF SESSION WE
FACED A REAL DILEMMA. WORKING
WITH DOCTOR WEBER AND SENATOR
BRADFORD AND OTHERS WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO GET HER LANDMARK
VITALLY IMPORTANT POLICE REFORM
BILL AB NINE THIRTY ONE OVER
SOME BIG HURDLES. BUT WHEN IT
BECAME CLEAR THAT WOULD NOT BE
THE VOTES TO PASS IN OUR HOUSE
OR CONCUR IN THE ASSEMBLY. I
GAVE DR WEBBER MY WORD. THAT
SHE WOULD KEEP WORKING ON THE
BILL WE WOULD WORK TOGETHER TO
PASS AT THE NEXT SESSION. AND
AFTER A YEAR OF DIFFICULT
MEETINGS AND PAINSTAKING
NEGOTIATIONS WE DID PASS AB
THREE NINETY TWO AND WHAT AN
INCREDIBLE TRIBUTE. THAT MR
LOVELL WAS ON THE PHONE
SPEAKING STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS CONFIRMATION. FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT. EVERYTHING I LOVE
AND RESPECT ABOUT SHIRLEY WEBER
WAS ON DISPLAY IN EVERY ONE OF
THOSE MEETINGS INCLUDING THE
RIGHTEOUSNESS OF RECALLS. THE
THOROUGHNESS OF HER PREPARATION
AND THEIR SHREWDNESS SHE
DISPLAYED IN ASSESSING
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS AND HOW
THEY WOULD IMPACT THE BILL'S
CHANCES OR MORE IMPORTANTLY HOW
THEY WOULD IMPACT THE BADLY
NEEDED CHANGES THE BILL WOULD
BRING ABOUT. OTHERS HAVE NOTED
THAT DR WEBER'S APPOINTMENT
MAKES HISTORY. I BELIEVE
SECRETARY OF STATE SHIRLEY
WEBER WILL ALSO DRIVE HISTORY
ESPECIALLY IN ENSURING
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP ON
VOTING RIGHTS AND VOTER
PARTICIPATION. FIFTY YEARS AGO
THIS MONTH A YOUNG KID NAMED
JERRY BROWN WAS SETTLING INTO
HIS NEW OFFICE AS CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE. BRING UP
OUR COPS SAID EARLIER. HE
WASN'T TWENTY THREE BUT HE WAS
PRETTY CLOSE AND DR SHIRLEY
WEBER I SEE A LOT OF THAT SAME
INTELLECT AND HUMOR FORTUNATELY
FOR ALL OF US NOT A LOT OF
LATIN SAYINGS YOU HAVE TO GO TO
GOOGLE TO TRANSLATOR UNDERSTAND
BUT AGAIN THE ELECT THAT THE
INTELLECT AND THE HUMOR. AND DR
SHIRLEY WEBER I SEE MORALITY
DETERMINATION AND LEADERSHIP
AND ALWAYS EMPATHY. N. AND DR
SHIRLEY WEBER I SEE
CALIFORNIA'S NEXT SECRETARY OF
STATE SO DOCTOR WEBER AGAIN
IT'S AN HONOR. AND WITH THAT-
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
FROM THE MAJORITY LEADER AND I
WOULD URGE A STRONG AYE VOTE.
M. SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
FAITH. NONVOTING HAVE SEEN
BATES NOT VOTING HERTZBERG BY.
I LAYERED I HEARD I WILL NOT
VOTING WILK NOT VOTING ATKINS
HI AND SAI THREE. ZERO THREE
VOTES YOU ARE CONFIRMED BY THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
CONGRADULATIONS DR WEBER. WILL
AND UP A VIRTUAL YOUR WAY MY
FRIEND. SO WE WILL- I AM GOING
TO CHECK OUT AND SEE WE'RE
GONNA AS WE TRANSITION INTO THE
NEXT SET OF HEARINGS LET ME
ALSO CONGRATULATE YOUR FAMILY
DOCTOR WEBER AS AS THEY- MADE
THE TRACK HERE OUR
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU I KNOW
YOU WILL SUPPORT AND SUSTAIN
HER IN THIS NEXT ENDEAVOR. I'M
GOING TO SEE- FROM OUR
STENOGRAPHER AINA IF YOU NEED A
BREAK. AT THIS MOMENT YES WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A FIVE MINUTE BREAK
AS WE TRANSITION INTO THE NEXT
PART OF OUR RULES COMMITTEE.
OKAY I AM PREPARING TO CALL THE
MEETING BACK INTO SESSION. BACK
TO ORDER. AND WE HAVE ONE
COLLEAGUE DATA. WILL BE
REJOINING US THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED- WE ARE ALL READY TO GO
SO NEXT ON OUR AGENDA
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR WE HAVE MEMBERS OF
THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD AND I'D TO
BOTH. MISS CYNTHIA FLORES AND
MISS VICTORIA HAS SEED LET ME
JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR%
PATIENCE- I SEE YOU ON THE
SCREEN- SO LET ME WELCOME BOTH
OF YOU AND LET YOU KNOW WE WILL
BEGIN WITH INTRODUCTIONS- FROM
MS FLORES SAID THEY WILL GO TO
MISSISSIPPI TO DO THE SAME.
AFTER EACH OF YOU HAVE GIVEN
YOUR INTRODUCTIONS OPENING
COMMENTS I INTRODUCED ANYONE
THAT MIGHT BE WITH YOU OR THAT
YOU WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE I'LL GO
TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS.
SO LET'S BEGIN WITH YOU MISS
FLORES- WELCOME AND GO AHEAD
AND- MAKE YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
INTRODUCE ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE
AND THE AND THEN WE WILL
PROCEED FROM THERE WELCOME.
THANK YOU I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I FIRST LIKE TO
THANK GOVERNOR IN DECEMBER AT
HIS APPOINTMENT TO THE AYLER B.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY
FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND ARE
WATCHING VIRTUALLY- FOR THEIR
UNWAVERING LOVE AND SUPPORT.
AND ABOVE ALL I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY MOTHER FOR
SERVING AS MY ROLE MODEL AND
INSPIRING ME TO PURSUE A CAREER
IN PUBLIC SERVICE. WATCHING HER
CONFRONT AND OVERCOME NUMEROUS
CHALLENGES AS AN UNDOCUMENTED
GARMENT WORKER. HAS INSPIRED ME
TO PURSUE A CAREER IN THE
FURTHERANCE OF JUSTICE FOR
THOSE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
SOCIETY. I AM HUMBLED AND
HONORED TO SERVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS A BOARD MEMBER
FOR THE AARP. DURING MY TENURE
I HOPE TO STRENGTHEN THE AARP'S
REACH BY ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS
AND PARTNERING WITH AFFILIATE
AGENCIES. SO THAT WE MAY BEST
MEET OUR MANDATE UNDER THE LAW.
SPECIFICALLY I WANT THE ARMY TO
BE A TRUSTED STATE AGENCY KNOWN
FOR ITS ABILITY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR CONSTITUENTS AND
EXPEDITIOUS AND EFFICIENT
MANNER. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LET ME MOVE TO
MISS A SEED WE WILL LET YOU GO
THROUGH YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
WELCOMES AND ACKNOWLEDGMENTS
AND THEY WILL GO TO MEMBERS
WELCOME. IT CAME OUT OF HER
TIME IN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
DISCUSS MY APPOINTMENT SERVICE
CHAIR THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD. I'D LIKE TO
THANK GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM AND
HIS TEAM FOR PUTTING THEIR
FAITH AND TRUST IN ME TO SERVE
IN THIS ROLE. AND LIKE MANY AS
MANY OF US HAVE SO MANY TO
THANK FOR WITHOUT THEM I WOULD
NOT BE HERE TODAY. MY FAMILY MY
HUSBAND DEREK MY PARENTS
MARRIED ANDRE MY SISTER ANNE
AND SO MANY FRIENDS COLLEAGUES
AND MENTORS. FOR THEIR WORDS OF
SUPPORT ENCOURAGEMENT AND
UNWAVERING BELIEF IN ME. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
WONDERFUL COLLEAGUES AND STAFF
I HAVE AT THE BOARD THEIR
DEDICATION AND COMMITMENT TO
THE WORK AND MISSION OF THE
BOARD IS UNPARALLELED. AND IT
IS SUCH A FORTUNATE SITUATION
THAT I HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET TO WORK ALONGSIDE SO MANY
WONDERFUL AND KNOWLEDGEABLE
COLLEAGUES. I'VE SPENT MY PAST
DECADE OF MY PROFESSIONAL
CAREER AND SERVICE TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I'VE HAD THE
WONDERFUL PLEASURE OF SERVING
IN STRENGTH AND FOCUSING MY
CAREER. ON STRENGTHENING AND
ENHANCING PROTECTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA WORKERS. I TAKE THIS
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE
INTO THIS NEW ROLE AS CHAIR OF
THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD. TO THAT END I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE SOME OF MY
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES AND
SERVING IN THIS ROLE. I SEE MY
PRIMARY DUTY IS TO JUDICATA
MATTERS. BEFORE ME BOTH FAIRLY
AND SWIFTLY AND TO ENSURE THAT
THE PROTECTIONS OF THE LRA ARE
FULLY REALIZED AND ACCESSIBLE
FOR OR ALL CALIFORNIA FARM
WORKERS. I ALSO CONSIDERED ARE
CHARGED TO PROVIDE EXTENSIVE
EDUCATION OUTREACH TO
AGRICULTURAL IN CANNABIS
EMPLOYEES. EMPLOYERS
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATIONS
UNIONS AND THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SERVE THEM.
THIS OUTRAGE MUST BE
COMPREHENSIVE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT AND ACCESSIBLE FOR
ALL. AS CHAIR IS ALSO MY CHARGE
TO OVERSEE THE BOARD AS AN
ORGANIZATION AND ENSURE THAT WE
ARE NOT ONLY COMPLIANT WITH
ALL. STATE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS. BUT THAT WE ARE
FIRST RATE STATE AGENCY. TO
THAT END MY OBJECTIVE IS TO
pTHOSE WHO ARE DEDICATED TO
CAREERS IN PUBLIC SERVICE.
FOSTER COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING
FIRST RATE PUBLIC SERVICE TO
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. AND
FOSTERING A CULTURE OF
COLLABORATION INNOVATION AND
INCLUSIVITY. AND IN CLOSING I
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT TO JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TREMENDOUS
IMPACT THE COPA NINETEEN HAS
HAD UPON THIS INDUSTRY THAT WE
SERVE. I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE HARD WORK OF THE EMPLOYERS
HAD TO NAVIGATE A VERY
DIFFICULT SITUATION AND ENSURE
THEY'RE KEEPING THEIR WORKERS
SAFE. AND I ALSO NEED TO SHARE
MY DEEP GRATITUDE AND
ADMIRATION FOR THE MILLIONS OF
THOUSANDS OF FARM WORKERS
ACROSS THE STATE. WHO GONE TO
WORK EVERY DAY OFTENTIMES AT
GREAT RISK TO THEIR PERSONAL-HEALTH AND SAFETY TO ENSURE WE
HAVE COULD NOT ONLY ON OUR
TABLE. ON TABLES ACROSS THE
WORLD. IT IS THIS DEDICATION
AYE I'M SO AT I'M IN DEEP
ADMIRATION I HAVE. AND IS ONLY
FURTHER MY RESOLVE TO SERVE IN
THIS ROLE TO THE BEST OF MY
ABILITIES WITH THAT I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COM. I'M GONNA GO
TO MEMBERS NOW AND AS I TURNED
TO SENATOR BATES- CENTER BATES
I'M GOING TO ASK TWO THINGS
ONE. MAKE SURE- YOUR- PHONE OR
OTHER DEVICES ARE MUTED I THINK
THE STENOGRAPHER I HAD A LITTLE
BIT OF A HARD TIME HEARING YOU
BEFORE SOMEONE MAKE SURE WERE
IN. GOOD OR WE'RE GOOD WITH
THAT AND- MAYBE AGAIN FOR THE
RECORD IF THERE'S ANYONE WITH
YOU IN THE ROOM YOU COULD
ANNOUNCE THAT PERSON AND THEN
WE WILL GO TO YOUR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. BOB HERE TODAY WITH
ME IS MY EXECUTIVE ASSISTANT TO
RESTRICTING- AND I MET MY
DISTRICT OFFICE SO. BY YEAH
SHE'S HERE IN AND OUT ONTO THE
QUESTIONS CONGRATULATIONS SIDE
TO BOTH OF YOU FOR. THIS
APPOINTMENT TIME BIG JOB AND
ESPECIALLY AS WE ARE NAVIGATING
ALL OF US THE COLD DAMAGEON
SITUATION AND WHAT THAT MEANS
TO OUR- FARMWORKERS AND
CERTAINLY THE EMPLOYEE OR SOME.
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS- I AM VERY
IMPRESSED WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION MUST A SEAT. AND I
KNOW THAT SOUNDS OUT ON VERY
STRONG COMMITMENT IN CERTAINLY
AND MY OUT REACH ARE YOU HAVE.
YOU KNOW GOTTEN GOOD COMMENTS
THAT YOU HAVE THAT BALANCE SO.
SO YOU CERTAINLY HAVE MY
SUPPORT I DON'T HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FOR MISS
FLORES ALSO YOUNG JUST JUMPING
IN HERE IN BIG MAIN JOB THAT. I
DIDN'T RECEIVE OUR QUESTIONS
FROM ON MY OUT REACH STATE THEY
DON'T REALLY KNOW YOU MISS
FLORIDA SO. I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT PROBABLY IS
GOING TO BE ON YOUR TO DO LIST
OF IT IS ALREADY THAT SHE DO
SOME. MORE OUT OF REACH SO- ALL
OF THE QUALIFICATIONS AND THE
COMMITMENT THAT YOU HAVE TO
BOTH SIDES. OF THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY ARE REPRESENTED WILL
BE CERTAINLY I'M SURE ON THE
TOP OF YOUR LIST. BUT I TRIED
WILL FIND MYSELF- CERTAINLY IN
SUPPORT AND I THINK ON. I'M I'M
KIND OF BACK AND FORTH ON THEM
STATING I DO MISS FLORES NOT
PERSONAL BUT I DON'T WANT THOSE
FOLKS THAT AND REACH OUT TO ME-
TALK TO ME ABOUT MISS FLORES
AND I SAID. SHE'S I'M SURE
SHE'S PREPARING TO BE OUT THERE
WE HAVE- IN MY DISTRICT SENATE
DISTRICT THIRTY SIX WE HAVE A
LARGE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY.
IN THE EASTERN PART OF. THE
NORTH SAN DIEGO COUNTY SO
WITHOUT SOME OF THEM YOU KNOW
YOU KNOW MOVE LET MY COLLEAGUES
TAKE OVER AND DONE. AWAY TO WE
GET TO THE VILLAGE AND THEN
I'LL BE LISTENING TO THE
QUESTIONS THAT COME YOUR WAY
AND WE'LL MAKE THAT DECISION
DOWN BUT- AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS
AND IT'S GREAT. TO SEE NOT TWO
WOMEN HERE- WHO SO COMMITTED TO
AN END OF. THAT'S SO. IN
CREDIBLY EMPLOYER. CHEN AND
FOUNDATIONS TO OUR SIX OF THE
STATE INCOME. SILICON ACTUALLY.
AND WE SHOULD VERY BEST. THANK
YOU SENATOR BATES MISTER CHAIR
I'LL GO TO YOU THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MAYOR PRO TEM CONGRATS- TO
BOTH U. ON YOU POINT- MISTER
SEA I HAVE QUESTION FOR YOU BUT
HONESTLY I'VE GOTTEN SO MUCH
POSITIVE FEEDBACK I'M JUST I
JUST DON'T WANT TO BURN TIME.
COUNTY YOUR QUESTION- SO I'M
NOT GOING TO DO THAT SO MISS
FLORES AT A SIMILAR. TO CENTER
BATES- NOT A LOT OF KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT YOU SO I JUST WANNA THROW
SOMETHING OUT OF THE WAY TO
HELP ME MAKE A DECISION AND- SO
IN YOUR OPINION WHAT IS THE
ROLE OF THE A. L. R. B. WHEN IT
COMES TO BALANCING THE RIGHTS
OF FARMWORKERS. EMPLOYERS IN
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS UNION.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. WONDERFUL I BELIEVE THAT
THE ROLE OF THE AYLER B. IS TO
ADJUDICATE MATTERS ANY FAIR AND
JUDICIOUS MANNER- I DO HAVE A
BACKGROUND AS AN IMMIGRATION
LITIGATOR. I'M VERY FAMILIAR
WITH POLICIES PROCEDURES AT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW LEVEL- AND
I'M DEEPLY COMMITTED TO
UPHOLDING MY ROLE AS A CLASS
AYE JUDICIAL OFFICER. THE
FORMER OFFICER OF THE COURT-
DO. YOU THINK VERY THOUGHTFULLY
ON THOSE MATTERS ARE BROUGHT
BEFORE OR BOARD IF THE BUZZER
AT THE LIMITATIONS. ARE PLACED
ON THIS BOARD BOTH WITHIN THE
CONFINES OF THE LINE ALSO OUR
PROCESS FEES. AS YOU ARE
PROBABLY FAMILIAR THE AYLER B.
AS- THE BILL FUNCTION WE DO
HAVE A GENERAL COUNSEL SIDE
WHICH SIR IS THAT THE
PROSECUTOR. OF CHARGES- AND
REALIZES THEM BEFORE IN THE
GREAT. INDUSTRY TO BLOT JUDGE-
AND THEN THE L. R. B. SERVICE-
IN. A PALLET FUNCTION SO- ALL
THE BACK TO SAY THAT I'M VERY
AWARE. THAT THE ELLERBEE'S.
JERRY AND MAY IS GOVERNED BY
THE LAW- AND AGAIN I HOLD-
BURST. VERY VERY VERY HIGH- ANY
I'M I'M AWARE OF THE NEED TO
HONOR ROLLS ON THE- OF
APPOINTED OFFICE- AN EXAMPLE
THAT COMES TO MIND IS THAT I
DID SERVE ON THE UC BOARD OF
REGENTS FOR TWO YEARS AS A
STUDENT REGION- AND WAS ABLE TO
MEET MY DUTIES AS A BOARD
MEMBER WHILE AT THE SAME TIME.
HONORING THAT THE NEEDS OF MY
CONSTITUENCY AND I THINK IF YOU
ASK ANYONE THAT SERVED ON THE
ON THAT BOARD- THEY HAVE A VERY
HIGH RESPECT AND ESTEEM FOR MY
ABILITY TO DO JUST THAT- THAT
WAS NEARLY TEN YEARS AGO I'D
LIKE TO THINK THAT I'VE I'VE
LEARNED A LOT- THEY GROWN AS. A
LEADER- IN THAT. SPAN OF TIME
AND SO- I'M GONNA ON ON MY-
EXPERIENCE OF THE BILL MY
DUTIES IN THIS YEAR ALL. RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MAYOR TEM. THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIRMAN. MR MAJORITY LEADER
LET ME ASK YOU TO GO NEXT.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR. THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO SPEND
WITH ME TO INTERVIEW- I JOIN IN
THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE SO FAR WITH RESPECT TO
YOUR RESPECTIVE REDENTIALS AND
I THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE I THINK
THIS IS A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
BOARD I WAS AROUND IN THE DAYS
WHEN THIS WAS CREATED AS I
MENTIONED TO BOTH OF YOU. AND
THINK THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
DOING I WANT TO SHARE THAT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO DO ON
THE RECORD. IS THAT WE IN THE
GOVERNMENT- THOSE OF US WHO
WERE SITTING HERE- LIKED IT
WERE HELD ACCOUNTABLE. BUT TO
THE PUBLIC IN A WAY THROUGH AN
ELECTION THE GOVERNOR YOU'RE
APPOINTING OFFICERS THE SAME.
IN ORDER TO MANAGE GOVERNMENT
WE DELEGATE AUTHORITY. TO
RESPONSIBLE AND THOUGHTFUL BUCS
FOLKS IN THE COMMUNITY TO HELP
US IN THAT REGARD TO LITIGATE
CASES IN THE LIKE. AND I JUST
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO IS WE
ACCESSIBLE IN THIS AS WORKABLE
AS POSSIBLE NEVER TAKE AWAY
ANYBODY'S ENTHUSIASM BUT ALWAYS
JUST. PHAM UNDERSTAND THAT
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHAT SIDE THEY
ARE ON- SHE SAYS TO EVERYONE
WHO INTERFACES US WITH US. IN
THE PUBLIC IS SO IMPORTANT AND
SO AS- I'M HOPEFUL THAT YOU
BOTH WILL BE CONFIRMED I THINK
THAT YOUR GREAT APPOINTEES AND
CONGRATULATE THE GOVERNOR FOR
DOING SO AND YOU FOR. TAKING ON
THIS RESPONSIBILITY BUT JUST TO
NEVER FORGET NEVER FORGET THAT
AWESOME RESPONSIBILITY AND HOW
EVERYONE LOOKS AT YOU BECAUSE
OF THE AUTHORITY THAT YOU HOLD
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHETHER YOU'RE FOR THEM OR
AGAINST THEM BUT TO ALWAYS
TREAT THEM WITH GRACIOUSNESS
KINDNESS AND RESPECT. IF YOU
EXERCISE THE POWER OF
GOVERNMENT THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MR MAJORITY
LEADER NOW YOU KNOW WHY HE'S
THE MAJORITY LEADER. I THANK
YOU FOR THAT- SENATOR LAYERED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LET ME
THANK EACH OF YOU FOR MEETING
WITH ME AS WELL AND I ALSO
KNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT. BOTH
OF YOU GOT A POINTED RIGHT AT
THE OUTBREAK OF THE PANDEMIC
AND I'VE NOT HAD A CHANCE TO
DO. SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO DO. R. AS BOARD
MEMBERS BECAUSE OF THE
LIMITATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
PLACED. HAVE A QUESTION FOR
EACH OF YOU AND LET ME START
WITH MISS I SAID. AND IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE IN OUR-
CONVERSATION. AND I MENTIONED
AS THE MAJORITY LEADER DID
IT'S- I WORKED RIGHT OUT OF
COLLEGE FROM THE CONGRESSIONAL
STAFF OF JURY WALDIE. WHO THEN
WAS APPOINTED TO THE HEY ALL L.
R. B. BY JERRY BROWN SHORTLY
AFTER THE BOARD WAS CREATED.
AND IT WAS EXPLOSIVE IN THAT
ERA. THERE WAS LOTS OF DIVISION
THAN YESTERDAY WHEN WE WERE
TALKING YOU MENTIONED. THAT
THAT SEEMS TO BE HISTORY IN
SOME WAYS AND I WOULD LIKE FOR
YOU TO TALK ABOUT THAT
PROGRESSION WHY YOU SEE. THE
BOARD FUNCTIONING WELL AND
PEOPLE GETTING ALONG THE STAKES
WERE TRICKS PERIODS IS WITH
THAT. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CENTER LAYERED I THINK.
I THINK I AM ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS THAT THERE HAS BEEN
SUCH A COLLEGIALITY AS YOU KNOW
AS BOARD MEMBERS WE WILL EACH
HAVE OUR WN OPINIONS I THINK
WE HAVE I HAVE TRIED AND I KNOW
THE OTHER BOARD MEMBERS HAVE
ALSO WORKED. TO INSTILL A
CULTURE OF CIVILITY AND
COLLEGIALITY AT THE BOARD SO IT
LEAST INTERNALLY WE ARE ABLE TO
DO THAT- AS BOARD MEMBERS YOU
KNOW IT CERTAINLY. AND PASSAGE
OF THE L. R. A. I KNOW IT WAS A
VERY FIERCE BATTLE TO GET THIS
ACT PASSED IN CREATED TO CREATE
THE BOARD. AND THAT SOME OF
THOSE TENSIONS YOU KNOW HAD
PRECEDED THE CREATION OF THE
BOARD FOR OVER A DECADE AND I
THINK CONTINUED ON. AND WHILE I
DO THINK THERE ARE STILL SOME
OF THAT THAT STRIFE I THINK
OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE
DEVELOPED A WAY TO COMMUNICATE
WITH ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
TO ASSURE ASSURE EVERYONE THAT
WE ARE- ACTING AS JUDICIAL
APPROPRIATELY IS JUDICIAL
OFFICERS WITHOUT BIAS BUT JUST
FURTHERING OUR DUTIES AND
THAT'S A GOLD A TENER BUT I
HOPE TO CARRY FORWARD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
ANSWER AND LET ME THEN GO TO.
TO MISS FLORES BECAUSE I WAS
ORIGINALLY GOING TO ASK. A
VERSION OF THE QUESTION THAT-
OF SENATOR WELCOME PASSED. BUT
LET ME ASK YOU GIVEN THE ANSWER
THAT YOU JUST HEARD FROM THE
CHAIR. HOW DO YOU PLACE
YOURSELF IN THAT COLLEGIALITY
AND SORT OF THE ABILITY TO WORK
AND LOOK AT THOSE. INTERESTS
AND WHAT YOUR DUTIES WOULD BE.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION- I
SEE MYSELF AS A BOARD MEMBER AS
PART OF A TEAM- I RECOGNIZE
THAT I HAVE A SINGLE VOTE- AND
I WORK ON TO I BRING A
PERSPECTIVE OF BACKGROUND
EXPERIENCE THAT INFORMS OUR
COLLECTIVE WORK- I DO HAVE
GREAT RESPECT AND ESTEEM FOR
CHAIR HIS FEET- I'VE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING TOGETHER A FEW MONTHS
WELL. ALMOST SIX EIGHT MONTHS
NOW- AND I IS INCREDIBLY
GIFTED- AND I THINK OF MYSELF
AS A BOARD MEMBER- IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO BE A TEAM
PLAYER BUT ALSO TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE VISION- AND
WHERE SHE'S DRIVING OUR OUR
ORGANS ARE AGENCY- AND- I THINK
SHE'S INCREDIBLY. WELL EQUIPPED
TO DO SO. IN SO GENERAL WHEN
YOU RESPONDED TO SENATOR WILL
YOU LOOK YEARS AS YOURSELF AS
QUASI JUDICIAL AND THEREFORE IT
IS NOT AN ADVOCATE A 100% OF
THE TIME AND YOU'RE
PARTICIPATING IN A VERY COOLEY
COOPERATION OUT BOB. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU BELIEVE THAT
YOU BRING TO THIS APPOINTMENT.
SAID CORRECT. YES I DO I THINK
WE WILL RESPECTFULLY I KNOW AND
I HAVE THE BACKGROUND BOTH THE
LEGAL EXPERIENCE BUT ALSO THE
EXPERIENCE IN GOVERNANCE TO
EXCEL. IN THIS POSITION AS A
BOARD MEMBER BUT ALSO SERVED ON
NUMEROUS BOARDS- THAT OBVIOUSLY
REQUIRE COLLECTIVE ENGAGEMENT.
BEIJING AND IMPLEMENTING PLANS
OF ACTION AND- NAY I FIRMLY.
BELIEVE THAT I CAN DO A VERY
GOOD JOB RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE. THANK YOU
SENATOR- WE ARE GOING TO. TURN
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FIRST A REMINDER FOR
WITNESSES WISHING TO PROVIDE
COMMENT VIA PHONE THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER.
MAY APPEAR ON THE SCREEN AGAIN
I HOPE IT'S. 844-291-6364
ACCESS CODE NINE TWO FOUR ONE
FOUR FIVE EIGHT. AGAIN EIGHT
FOUR FOUR IS THE NUMBER TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
ACCESS CODE. NINE TWO FOUR ONE
FOUR FIVE EIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THIS ROOM ROOM FOR
TWO OH THREE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. I AM SEEING
NO ONE HERE SO LET ME FOR THE
PURPOSES OF PROCESS GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE. TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO
ONE STEPPING TO THE MIKE ARE I
WILL TURN TO THE
TELECONFERENCE. AND TWO
WITNESSES WHO MAY BE WANTING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
ARE STILL WITH US WE PLEASE
PROBABLY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
APPOINTMENTS. FOR MISS FLORES
AND MISS A SEAT. THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN TO EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT
ME PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN
NOT TO ONE AND THEN THEY'RE ALL.
WE HAVE A FEW LINES IN Q. FIRST
IN LINE SEVENTEEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN OKAY YEAH HI DADDY GRANDMA
ALL LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH
THE F. B. W. WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL AND I AM HONORED TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF MESQUITE
NEED TO RE APPOINTMENT AS CHAIR
OF THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD I THINK THE
CHAMBER THE LRB WITH
SIGNIFICANT EXPERIENCE AND BAY
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AND GREAT
EXPERTISE IN LABOR AND
INDUSTRIALPOLICY. THE FIRM HAS
A CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN WHERE SHE
SERVED IN SEVERAL POSITIONS IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE INCLUDING
ACTING DIRECTOR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF LEGISLATION AND POLICY AND
SPECIAL COUNSEL. EARNED A JURIS
DOCTOR DEGREE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS
SCHOOL OF LAW IN HALL AS A
BOARD MEMBER AT ELLERBEE AND
CHAIR OF THE BOARD YET THAT THE
TO CONTINUE TO BE WIDELY
RESPECTED BY ALL STAKEHOLDERS
HER LEGAL ACCU MEN AND A
COMMITMENT TO THE ELLERBEE'S
MESONET ENSURING COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS FOR
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS. HAVE
STRENGTHENED THE BOARD AND
BENEFIT WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS
THROUGHOUT THE INDUSTRY TO
PROVIDED LET ME A LET ME LET ME
NOT LET ME STOP YOU FOR A QUICK
SECOND I'M SO SORRY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE CAPTURE YOUR
TESTIMONY AT OUR STENOGRAPHER
IS ASKING IF YOU COULD. SLOW
DOWN SO IF YOU'LL BACK UP A
SENSOR TO WITH GREAT
APPRECIATION I ASK YOU TO SLOW
DOWN IN YOUR COMMENTS WE HAVE
TOP. THANK YOU SORRY TO
INTERRUPT YOU. YEAH OF COURSE
YEAH SORRY ABOUT THAT. I'M HOW
DID START OVER SLOWLY YESTERDAY
CAME THE L. R. B. RESTING
EXPERIENCE AND BAKER OP. AND
GREAT EXPERTISE AND LABOR AND
THAT PAUL. MAGAZINE SERVED AS
THE CHIEF THAT TO AT THE CAL
DEPARTMENT OF AND RELATIONS IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN THIRD
IMPOSSIBLE POSITIONS AND TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE INCLUDING
ACTING DIRECTOR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF LEGISLATION AND POLICY AND
SPECIAL COUNSEL MISTER SEED
EARNED A JURIS DOCTOR DEGREE
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS SCHOOL OF LAW.
AT THE PART NUMBER AT L. R. B.
AND TERRIBLE BOARD SEAT HAD
CONTINUED TO BE WIDELY
RESPECTED BY ALL STAKEHOLDERS-
LEGAL ACCU MEN AND A COMMITMENT
TO THE ELLERBEE'S MISSION OF
ENSURING COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
RIGHTS FOR AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
HAVE STRENGTH IN THE BOARD AND
BENEFITTED WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS THROUGHOUT THE
INDUSTRY. TO PROVIDE LEADERSHIP
TO THE BOARD AS THAT NAVIGATE A
COMPLEX LEGAL MATTERS AND
DOCUMENTATION SERVICES THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC FREDDIE REASONS
THE FTW HONORED WITH APARTMENT
THE SEAT ON A REAPPOINTMENT AS
CHAIR OF THE L. R. B. THANK YOU
AND APOLOGIES AGAIN. NO THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE ABLE TO- TO GET THE
CLEAR- TESTIMONY MISTER
MODERATOR. I'D NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU GO TO LINE OF LINE
NOW. ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND OF THE
MISTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FOR PICKED UP TO THE
TESTIFIED TODAY WE'RE JUST YOUR
SPEAK IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
VICTORIA AND SEE THE POINT THAT
TO THE L. R. B. WE HAVE A-
PRETTY EXTENSIVE HISTORY OF
WORKING WITH HER DURING HER
TIME AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS. WHERE SHE
COVERED A LOT OF VERY
COMPLICATED ISSUE AREAS LIKE
WORKERS COMPENSATION WORKER
HEALTH AND SAFETY WAGE AND
HOUR- AND YOU KNOW THESE ARE
VERY. THE ISSUE AREAS THAT ARE
CERTAINLY TAKING ME A LONG TIME
TO WRAP MY HEAD AROUND BUT SHE
ALWAYS PICKED THINGS UP VERY
QUICKLY WASALWAYS INCREDIBLY
COMPETENT AND EFFECTIVE AND
ACCESSIBLE. NO MATTER WHAT THE
ISSUE AREA WAS AND WE ALWAYS
FOUND HER TO BE AN ADDITIONAL
ALL OF THOSE THINGS VERY FAIR
TO ALL SIDES WE NEVER HEARD ANY
COMPLAINTS FROM THE EMPLOYER
SIDE ON ANY OF THOSE ISSUES.
AND FROM ALL ACCOUNTS SHE'S
BRINGING ALL OF THOSE QUALITIES
TO HER ROLE AT THE L. R. B. AND
WE WOULD STRONGLY URGE THAT
THOSE CONTINUE AND AGAIN WOULD
JUST SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF HER
APARTMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR OTHER
WITNESSES. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHER WITNESSES IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY WE
WILL GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE- TWO FOUR TWO OH THREE THE
ROOM THAT WERE IN AND GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO. WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AND
ALREADY I SEE THAT THERE IS NO
ONE HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
I WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
JUST TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE. NO
ONE WAITING TO SPEAK THEIR-
OKAY I SEE NO ONE STEPPING
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. SO MR
MODERATOR I'M COMING BACK TO
YOU FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO MIGHT WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU COULD YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THANK
YOU THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q.
MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE SO I
WILL BRING IT BACK. TO FOR TWO
OH THREE TO SEE IF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. AND I AM
HAPPY TO TAKE A MOTION FOR-
ITEM ONE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS REQUIRED TO APPEAR
MISS CYNTHIA FLORES AND MS
VICTORIA A SEAT. THE MOVED.
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN HAS MADE A
MOTION- LET ME JUST ADD- YOU
KNOW I WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH
FOR YOUR SERVICE OBVIOUSLY-
THESE ARE DIFFICULT DAYS IN
WHICH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
SERVICE. I FOUND THE YOUR
LEADERSHIP MRS SEED FIVE YOU
KNOW THE COMMENTS OF THE
QUESTIONS I ANSWERED THROUGH
OUR PROCESS I GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT.
IT'S REALLY EXCITING TO SEE A
NEW MEMBER OF THE OARD MISS
FLORES APPOINTED AND- YOU KNOW
I THINK DIVERSITY INCLUDES MANY
FACTORS INCLUDING- NEW
LEADERSHIP THAT WE SEEK TO
ADVANCE IN PUBLIC SERVICE AND
SO. I AM PROUD TO SUPPORT BOTH
OF YOU AND APPRECIATE. YOUR
YOUR SERVICE TO OUR STATE.
MADAM SECRETARY AND THANK YOU
MR VICE CHAIRMAN FOR THE MOTION
WE WILL TAKE BOTH AT THE SAME
TIME PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BATES I IT'S AYE HERTZBERG BY
PROVIDE LAYERED HI THERE I WILL
CONFINE LOOK AYE ATKINS FIVE
FIVE THAT IS UNANIMOUS
CONGRATULATIONS TO BOTH OF YOU
AND THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU.
OKAY OUR NEXT ITEM I'M JUST
GONNA TAKE A LOOK AND MAKE SURE
OUR SITE IN ORDER FOR IS GOOD
TO GO. UNION OKAY WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE FORWARD- THIS NEXT
APPOINTMENT HI IS GIDEON CRACK
OFF WHO WILL BE OUR HAS BEEN
APPOINTED AS MEMBER OF THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT- MR CRACK
UP THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE-
I'M WAITING TO SEE HIM COME ON
SCREEN THERE YOU ARE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WE
WANT TO SAY WELCOME TO YOU AND
ASK THAT IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE OPENING COMMENTS FEEL FREE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK ANYONE
IS THAT YOU WOULD LIKE THAT
COULD BE WITH YOU OR THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO. AND THEN WILL GO
TO MY COLLEAGUES SO WELCOME.
THANK YOU. FOR TEN ATKINS CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN YES WE
CAN. PORTEND ATKINS VICE CHAIR
WILK AND MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE IT'S AN HONOR FOR ME
TO BE HERE BEFORE YOU AS THE
NOMINEE FOR THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
GOVERNING BOARD. ONE OF THE
GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR TRUSTING ME
WITH THIS NOMINATION. AND MY
FAMILY AND WIFE MISTY IN
PARTICULAR FOR ALL THE SUPPORT
IN MAKING IT POSSIBLE FOR ME TO
PURSUE PUBLIC SERVICE. TODAY
I'LL TOUCH JUST BRIEFLY ON MY
GOALS FOR THE SOUTH COAST HQ
ANTI. LOCK ABOUT MY PERSPECTIVE
AND EXPERIENCE IN LISTENING TO
YOU ABOUT YOUR PRIORITIES FOR
THE DISTRICTS WORK. I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A LONG DAY FOR THE
COMMITTEE AND THE STENOGRAPHERS
OF ALL BE CONCISE. EVERYTHING
I'M GOING TO DO WITH THE
DISTRICT. IS WILL BE TAILORED
TO OUR MISSION. TO CLEAN THE
AIR AND PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
ALL RESIDENTS IN THE SOUTH
COAST. AIR DISTRICT YOUR
PRACTICAL. AND INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES THIS MISSION IS
TAKING ON EVEN MORE IMPORTANCE
IN THIS TIME THE PANDEMIC AND
WILDFIRES. ACHIEVING COMPLIANCE
WITH THE FEDERAL ALL THE
STANDARDS PARTICULARLY THE
FEDERAL EIGHT HOUR OZONE
STANDARD OR OUR EXTREME NON
ATTAINMENT AREA BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR IS A KEY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR OUR BOARD.
STING EXTENSIVE INCENTIVE
FUNDING STAFF RESOURCES
INCLUDING OR ZERO AND NEAR ZERO
TECHNOLOGIES PARTICULARLY FOR
OUR PORT DRAYAGE TRUCKS. THE
BEST WAY TO HELP GET NEEDED
OZONE REDUCTIONS IN THE TIME
REMAINING BEFORE OUR ATTAINMENT
DATE IT'S CERVANTES INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS THE TURN OVER THE
EXISTING FLEET THE CLEANEST
AVAILABLE MODELS. ANOTHER
PRIORITY SANDERS IS THE
REDUCTION OF TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS THAT YES. OUR AIR
TOXICS REDUCTION WORKER ALSO TO
AB SIX ONE SEVEN WHICH IS
DESIGNED TO ACHIEVE LOCAL
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES OUR
DISTRICT HAS FIVE OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND A KEY PRIORITY
IS TO ENSURE THAT EIGHTY SIX
SIX SEVENTEEN. UP TO ITS
PROMISE. MEMBER OF THE BOARD
SENATORS I BRING A DIVERSE
EXPERIENCE AND PERSPECTIVE.
EIGHTY FIVE YEARS AS A LAWYER
AND WORK WITHIN GOVERNMENT
INDUSTRY LABOR AND
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE DOCTORS ALSO HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING ON SEVERAL
OTHER STATE BOARDS IN THE PAST.
THESE ROLES TAUGHT ME THE VALUE
OF COLLEGIALITY CIVILITY WITH
FELLOW BOARD MEMBERS AND STAFF
THE VALUE OF BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
BASED ON TRUST AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IMPORTANT A GOOD
LISTENER. TO UNDERSTAND THE
INTERESTS OF MY OTHER BOARD
MEMBERS. AND FUNDING TO UP TO
DO THE WORK AND BE RELIABLE AND
THAT'S WHAT HELPS SMALL
CONSENSUS ON DIFFICULT ISSUES.
SO TO CONCLUDE A CHAIR ATKINS
VICE CHAIR WILL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M READY TO WORK AND
IF CONFIRMED WOULD FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH YOU. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS NOW I
GAVE MY DOGS AND CHEW TOYS SO
THERE SHOULD BE NO PARKING. BUT
THAT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. WELL YOUR DOGS ARE
OBVIOUSLY BETTER THAN MINE I.
IN THIS WORLD OF ZOOM- LET ME
GO AHEAD AND GO MISTER MAJORITY
LEADER TO YOU AND LET YOU START
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MATT APPROACH- YOU KNOW I JUST
WANT TO OF- TECHNOLOGY AT THE
OUTSET HERE- THAT I MIGHT HAVE
SOMEWHAT OF A- CHALLENGE ON
THIS APPOINTEE BECAUSE AND I
THINK IT WAS NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR I GAVE HIM. SOME RESEARCH
WORK TO DO AND I HAVEN'T SEEN
THE WORK PRODUCT YET. WHEN HE
WAS A BRAND NEW OF THE USING A
LAURIE IS A LAWYER TO WORK ON
SOME ISSUES RELATING TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I GUESS I
COULD TAKE IT BACK AND SAY THAT
HE PROBABLY DID I PROBABLY
FORGOT THAT HE DID THE WORK
BUT- NO I MAKE. IT LOOK I I'M
EXCITED AND I THINK THAT-
GIDEON THE SWISS APPOINTEE HAS
A- NOMINEE HAS CIGNA IS A GREAT
BACKGROUND. I ONLY WANT TO
SHARE WITH HIM FOR THE RECORD
THAT. YOU KNOW I CERTAINLY HERE
WE ALL CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT. BUT IN BUT THE
CHALLENGES THERE'S THOUSANDS OF
BACKLOGGED CASES. THE FEES THAT
ARE CHARGED NEED TO BE LOOKED
AT. THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
OFTEN OR IS HALF THE COST OF
THE FEES. AND THAT YOU KNOW
AGAIN I THE ISSUE THE DIE BRING
TO THIS RULES COMMITTEE. AS WE
LOOK AT TO. MEMBERS AND WHO
WANT TO SERVE AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR TAKING THE TIME TO DO SO
FOR A WAS A HUNDRED DOLLARS A
DAY OR WHATEVER IT. IS A REALLY
DIFFICULT JOB. BUT THAT BUT
THAT YOU REALLY TAKE A HARD
LOOK AT SOME OF THE INTERFACE
IN TERMS OF HOW PEOPLE ON ALL
SIDES OF. THE EQUATION ARE
INTERFACING WITH GOVERNMENT AND
TRYING TO MAKE IT MORE
ACCESSIBLE MORE AVAILABLE
EASIER TO INTERFACE LESS
COSTLY. YOU KNOW AND IT OFTEN
FOLKS THAT WORK FOR US IN THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE JOBS FOCUS ON
THE DETAILS IN YOUR JOB AND
THAT. IS AN APPOINTEE OF
ELECTED OFFICIALS. IS TO HAVE
THE BIGGER PICTURE AND I KNOW
FROM OUR DISCUSSION YOU HAVE IT
I JUST WANTED TO MENTION THAT
BRIEFLY. AND AGAIN THANK YOU-
COUNSEL FOR INCLUDING IN
ADDITION TO CARBERRY DOING MORE
WORK ON THIS I KNOW IT'S A VERY
CHALLENGING YOUR LIFE TO DO
THIS I KNOW HOW MUCH WORK IT
TAKES. ME OUT CHALLENGING THESE
JOBS ARE AND HOW MUCH HOMEWORK
THERE IS AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
SOMEBODY. WHO'S GOING TO DO
YOUR HOMEWORK SO I JUST THANK
YOU FOR. FOR A PUTTING YOUR
NAME UP THANKING THE GOVERNOR
FOR POINTING YOU IN JUST
PLEASE- BE SENSITIVE TO THE
PEOPLE INTERFACE WITH AND
PLEASE BE DILIGENT. WITH
RESPECT TO UNDERSTANDING HOW
GOVERNMENT AFFECTS FOLKS AND
TRY TO THINK ABOUT IT EVERY DAY
AND BE CREATIVE. AND INNOVATIVE
IN THAT REGARD THANK YOU SIR.
SACRAMENTO THANK YOU SEE
LAYERED YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THE
HOURS LIGHT SO I'M JUST GOING
TO MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT RATHER
THAN ASK A QUESTION AND THAT IS
A SEARCH. I HAD THE EXPERIENCE-
THE OF BEING IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OR WE APPOINTED
OUR GIDEON AS CHAIR OF THE
MINING AND GEOLOGY BOARD. AND
WHEN EXPERIENCE WITH HIM
BECAUSE HE WAS ACTIVE IN THE
BARS WELL BOUGHT. WHEN WE DID
THAT IT WAS AN AGENCY THAT
WE'RE STRUGGLING WITH AN AGENCY
THAT HAD TROUBLE
ADMINISTRATIVELY IT WAS AN
AGENCY THAT HAD TROUBLE
BALANCING INTERESTS BETWEEN THE
SIDES. AND HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL
IN FIXING THE ADMINISTRATION
BALANCING IT VERY WELL AND WE
EVEN DID A MEASURE OF REFORM
THAT HE WAS INVOLVED IN THAT
WENT THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE.
AND ONE OF THE INTERESTING
THINGS TODAY IS THAT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
TAKEN A POSITION ON THIS
NOMINATION. THERE SOME PEOPLE
FROM THE INDUSTRY THAT HE
WORKED WITH IN THE MINING AND
GEOLOGY BOARD WHERE NORMALLY
YOU WOULD THINK HE'S ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE PEOPLE IN
THE INDUSTRY HAVE ENDORSED- OF
DISAPPOINTMENT. AND THAT IS A
VERY VERY SIGNIFICANT STATEMENT
AND SO I AM GRATEFUL THAT HE
MET WITH ME. AND IN THAT HE
JUST REAFFIRMED THE BALANCING
OF THESE INTERESTS IN A VERY
GOOD WAY AND I THINK HE HAS A
TRACK RECORD THAT PROVES HE
MEETS AT SO I'M GOING TO BE
VERY COMFORTABLE VOTING TO
CONFIRM HIM TODAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HI- N. SENATOR BATES I
HAVE NOT FORGOTTEN ABOUT YOU I
JUST FIGURED I'D LET YOU GO
LAST FOR A CHANGE MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN OF. YOUR DATE YEAH I
THINK ABOUT A PRO TEM. I JUST
WANT TO- ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG BECAUSE I
THINK. THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE
MOST APPROPRIATE AND I'M NOT TO
ASK ANY QUESTIONS EITHER-
NUMEROUS PEOPLE THAT I REALLY
RESPECT HAVE WORKED WITH YOU IN
THE PAST. AND HAD WE ARE JUST
GLOWING RED GLOWING REMARKS
ABOUT YOU AND EVEN THOUGH
YOU'RE PROBABLY LEFT TO CENTER
ND I'M CENTER RIGHT- AS
MEASURED BY CENTER LAYERED. YOU
ARE ABLE TO BRIDGE THAT GAP AND
THEY YOU'RE VERY OPEN MINDED
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO BE
SOLUTION ORIENTED SO WITH THAT
I'M LOOKING FORWARD. TO VOTING
FOR YOUR CONFIRMATION TODAY.
THANK YOU MR VICE MEASURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LET ME MOVE TO
SENATOR BATES. WE MADE IT VERY
EASY FOR ME ARE GOING LAST
BECAUSE I THINK EVERYBODY ALL
WHO SPOKE BEFORE CHECK EVERY
ONE OF MY THOUGHTS AND MY
QUESTIONS FOR MR CRACK OFF I
GUESS I HAVE ONE LAST MONTH HOW
DID YOU GET SO. OCULAR WE HAVE
SUCH GOOD RECORDS ON YOU ARE.
SO I IN MY YOU HAVE MY FULL
SUPPORT AND I THINK AS WE GO
FORWARD HOWEVER ON. I ALWAYS
HAVE ISSUES WITH WIVES JOB. THE
CARD HE REMEDIOS DOING WHERE
LET. THAT WE PASSED AND I THINK
THEY REACH BEYOND OFFER AND AT
THE ENTRANCE OF THE
LEGISLATURE. IN KIND OF A
COMMAND AND CONTROL. APPROACH
WITHOUT JOHN YOU KNOW SOME
BALANCE IN THERE SO- I KNOW
THAT YOU ARE SOMEONE WHO REALLY
DOES I EMPLOYED THAT BALANCING
OUR PERSPECTIVE NOT SO VERY
IMPORTANT WHEN YOU'RE DEALING.
WITH SOMETHING AS IMPORTANT AS
OUR AIR QUALITY BUT ALSO
KEEPING INDUSTRIES COAL IN
BEING ABLE TO CONTINUE WITH
RULES AND REGULATIONS THAT ARE
ADAPTABLE AND JOB. YOU SEEM TO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THAT IN
YOUR PREVIOUS SERVICE AND I
DON'T SEE THAT YOU WOULD BE
CHANGING OF THAT SO
CONGRATULATIONS THERE. YOU WILL
HAVE A MY SUPPORTS A STRONG
SUPPORTER THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME'S ON CENTER BATES AND I'M
I'M HOPEFUL- YOU KNOW THAT- I
CAN ESTABLISH- EVEN. STRONGER
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH YOUR
OFFICE- VICE CHAIR WILK I WANT
TO BE OPEN AT ALL TIMES UP TO
YOUR FEEDBACK- AND LEARN FROM
YOU SO I'M HOPING THAT- WE CAN
JUST CONTINUE TO GET TO KNOW
EACH OTHER. BETTER AND BETTER
AND- THAT I CAN EAT IT AN ALLY
NDA- ASSET FOR YOUR STAFFS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ISSUES AT
THE DISTRICT. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES I. YOU KNOW I DON'T HAVE
A QUIT AS MUCH AS A COP. ON YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE QUITE- A
REPUTATION- A. N. DIED TO LIVE
UP TO AND CERTAINLY THE HARD
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE AND THE
PEOPLE YOU'RE ABLE TO BRING
TOGETHER. RECOGNIZE IN THAT YOU
ARE. THEY ARE OF THE ON THE AIR
QUALITY- BOARD AS WELL AS A R.
B. AND CERTAINLY THOSE OF US
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE NOT THE
ONLY PART OF THE STATE THAT
SUFFERS FROM. A HARMFUL AIR
POLLUTION AND THE CHALLENGES
ARE BIG SO. I JUST WANT TO MAKE
A POINT THAT- YOU KNOW THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD PROBABLY. GONNA
HAVE TO REFOCUS EFFORTS ON- I'D
CLEAN AIR AND COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED AND I WISH YOU THE
BEST OF LUCK BECAUSE THIS IS A
DAUNTING CHALLENGE AS THE
FORMER SECRETARY OF. RESOURCES
KNOWS IT IS A MULTI FACETED.
ISSUE N. LOTS OF FACTORS THAT
THAT LEND TO THAT BUT- YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE-
CERTAINLY THE ARTICLES OF A
RECENT LOS ANGELES TIMES-
EDITORIAL STATING THAT THAT
THERE IS WORK TO BE DONE. I
WISH YOU THE BEST AND HOPEFULLY
WE CAN CONTINUE TO TALK AND
WHEN WORK ON THOSE ISSUES
TOGETHER BUT- I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE WITH MY COLLEAGUES- IN
TERMS OF THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS
NOMINATION. SO JUST WANTED TO
MAKE THAT COMMENT- MR MAJORITY
LEADER DID YOU WANT TO ADD DID
I SEE A OCEAN MEMBER TO ALL
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE IT WE HAVE
TO- WHY DON'T. WHY DON'T WE GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES IDEA. I DON'T I
THINK WE'VE BEEN TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC BUT NOT I'M SURE
GIVEN ALL OF THE POSITIVE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES THAT
MR CRACK UP IS GOING TO WANT TO
HEAR FROM. THE SUPPORTERS WHO
ARE OBVIOUSLY ON THE LINE SO
LET ME THOUGH HOWEVER START
WITH ROOM FOR TWO OH THREE- THE
ROOM THAT WE ARE IN AND SEE IF
I WELL SEEING NO ONE FROM THE
PUBLIC IN THIS ROOM. SUE ME NO
ONE IS STEPPING FORWARD TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. LET ME REPEAT
MOVED TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY SEE SOMEONE
STANDING IN SUPPORT- WELCOME. A
REMINDER TO STATE YOUR NAME
WHAT ORGANIZATION IF ANY YOU-
ARE REPRESENTING AND BRIEF
COMMENTS WELCOME. THANK YOU
CHAD CAN SLICE YOUR WELCOME
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
CHUCK CAL GET- I REPRESENT
REPUBLIC SERVICES- I'VE KNOWN
THE GIDEON AND WORK CLOSELY
WITH HIM FOR ON A NUMBER OF
YEARS NOW. AND KNOW THAT HIS
DECISIONS- ARE DETERMINED
THROUGH THOROUGH RESEARCH
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION
COMMONSENSE. AND HIGHEST
ETHICAL STANDARDS. IT'S NOT
OFTEN THAT I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT
WHOLEHEARTEDLY A FRIEND AND A
COLLEAGUE I WAS THERE FOR WITH
GREAT PLEASURE AND CONFIDENCE
THAT WE RECOMMEND TO YOU AND TO
THE STATE SENATE. THAT YOU
CONFIRM THE APPOINTMENT OF
GETTING CRACK UP TO THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
NEXT WITNESS JUROR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- MARC A PRAYER ON
BEHALF OF CHARGEPOINT ELECTRIC
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE COMPANY-
WE- WE FIRST WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR MAKING THIS
APPOINTMENT AND WE BASED ON OUR
BOTH PROFESSIONAL AND PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE
HARDLY- ENDORSE- THE-
APPOINTMENT AND CONFIRMATION OF
GETTING CRACK UP. THANK YOU
MISTER PRATT ANYONE ELSE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. OKAY SEEING NO
ONE ELSE MISTER MODERATOR I'M
GONNA COME BACK TO YOU AS PART
OF OUR TELECONFERENCE FOR FOLKS
WAITING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. GO FIRST
ON LINE TWENTY ONE TO ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SIX GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LISA METAL
ON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALL ME DAY SEQUIN I IN A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
WORKS TO IMPROVE AIR POLLUTION
AND ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
RIVERSIDE IMPERIAL COUNTIES WE
HAVE KNOWN AND THAT WORK WITH
MR CRACK UP FOR OVER A DOZEN
YEARS HE'S SMART THOUGHTFUL AND
DEEP UNDERSTANDING ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES
THAT AFFECT OUR REGION HE
LISTENS SHOWS UP AND ALWAYS
CARES WATER COMMUNITIES WE
SUPPORT HIM WITHOUT RESERVATION
FOR THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS X. THANK YOU AN
ALKALINE SIXTEEN ONE SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS REBECCA FEDERAL FAN I'M
A POLICY ADVOCATE WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL PROJECT
GOALS AND ACCOUNTABILITY BASED
IN THE EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY. I'D LIKE
TO SHARE OUR SUPPORT FOR MR
CRACK OF THE POINT MAN AS A
BOARD MEMBER WITH BARCODES HMD
MR CRACK BECAUSE HAVE BEEN VERY
ENGAGED IN THE AB ONE SEVEN
PROSPECT ACROSS SEVERAL
COMMUNITIES. INCLUDING THE
EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY CAN'T
PROVIDED HELPFUL GUIDANCE AND
SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITY
PRIORITIES AND CONTINUE TO HELP
BUT PUSH THEM FORWARD EVANDER
STANDING OF AND DEDICATION TO
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
COMMUNITY PRIORITY THE GREAT
AND THING THAT WE CAN'T
CONTRIBUTION TO THE FALCO
GOVERNING BOARD THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. HELLO TO LINE TWENTY.
TO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VERONICA BY THE EXAMPLE I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BEAUTIFUL AND WE ARE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS
SERVING THAT MARKET. VALLEY
I'VE KNOWN AND WORKED WITH
GIDEON FOR AT LEAST THE TEN
YEARS THAT I'VE DEMOCRATS ARE
BEAUTIFUL AND I REITERATE THAT
HE IS A SMART HUGHES DOT ONE
DIVISIBLE INDIVIDUAL. WHO HAS
DEFENDER STANDING ON BERMAN TO
ISSUES THAT AFFECT FROM LIKE
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE ONE RIGHT
THERE. I WAS EXCITED TO LEARN
OF HIS APPOINTMENT KNOWING HE'S
GOING TO BE THERE PROVIDING A
VOICE TO COMMUNICATE THAT FOR
TOO LONG HAVE REMAINED A
VOICELESS. KIND BASIS. SO I
KNOW WILL BE THERE AND THE
MEN'S YOU CAN BE A GOOD
LISTENER TO SHOW AND YOU'VE
FIGHT GONNA. FROM BERMAN THE-
FOR THAT I SUPPORT HIM WITHOUT
READ. THANK YOU VERY. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. GLOBAL CLIENT
FOUR TWO FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS BILL MCGOVERN WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
STRONG SUPPORT I WORK WITH
GIDEON FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
AND I KNOW HIM TO BE A
KNOWLEDGEABLE HARD WORKING AND
CONSCIENTIOUS ENVIRONMENTAL
LAWYER WITH A COMMITMENT TO
PUBLIC SERVICE. THE SOUTH COAST-DISTRICT FACES THE CHALLENGE OF
THE WORST SMOG IN THE ENTIRE
NATION AND NEEDS TO REDUCE
POLLUTION FROM MAJOR SOURCES OF
POLLUTION LIKE WAREHOUSES PORTS
AND REFINERIES. THE BREEDERS OF
THE SOUTH COAST REGION NEED
GIDEON'S VOICE AND EXPERTISE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. ORDERED ONLINE
TWENTY TWO ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS- DAVID FERRY NUMBER A CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA WASTE AND RECYCLING
ASSOCIATION. BUT WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO SUPPORT GIDEON'S
APPOINTMENT- BUT SHE W. R. A.
IS A TRADE ASSOCIATION WERE
COMPRISED OF. SMALL AND MEDIUM
SIZED PRIVATE WASTE RECYCLING
COMPANIES OPERATING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. MR CRACK UP IS
BETTER ATTORNEY FOR THE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS. AND HELPED US ON
REGULATORY AND LEGISLATIVE
ISSUES- IN SOME CASES- THERE
WERE TIMES IN OUR ASSOCIATION
SAW THINGS DIFFERENTLY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL INDUSTRY OR MAYBE
WHAT LABOR- BUT BUT- MISTER
CRACKED UP ALWAYS HAD THE
ABILITY TO BE LOYAL TO OUR
GROUP. I'M VERY THOUGHTFUL IN
HIS DELIVERY AND I MANY TIMES
WE ALWAYS ENDED UP WITH A GOOD
OUTCOME FOR BOTH SIDES. TO
WITHOUT WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT-
MR CROCK OFF WILL SERVE THE
BEST INTERESTS OF THE BOARD.
AND ITS POLICIES BASED ON OUR
FIFTEEN YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
WITH HIM AND IT'S WITHOUT
RESERVATION THAT WE WOULD
RECOMMEND HIM- FOR HIS
APPOINTMENT TO THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT WITNESS.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY FIVE
TWO FIVE WITH YOUR HEAD. HI
THIS IS DAVID PETTIT I'M A
LAWYER WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. I'VE
KNOWN AND WORKED WITH GIVING
FOR MANY YEARS AND EVEN ONCE
DEPOSED HIM IN THE MATTER AND I
HAVE THE HIGHEST REGARD FOR HIM
TO USE. SMART PREPARED HARD
WORKING IT WILL MAKE A GREAT
APPOINTMENT INTERVIEW STEVE
STRONGLY SUPPORTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. OUR NEXT WITNESS OF
THE LINE BETWEEN ONE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PRESIDENT PRO TEM
WHERE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS ADAM HARPER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRIAL MATERIALS
ASSOCIATION- WORST CROP IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A- TO CRACK
UP APPOINTMENT TO THE SOUTH
BECAUSE TURKEY WENDY- SENATOR
LAYERED- DID NOT. OVERSTATE HIS
BENEFITS TO STATE MINING
GEOLOGY BOARD AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. AS A
REMINDER EMAIL PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTEEN
ONE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE- MY NAME IS
TERRY THOMAS AND WITH EASTER
COMMUNITIES FROM BERMAN
ADJUSTED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
VERY FRIENDLY SUPPORT GIDEON
NOMINATE REPORT DIRECTLY WITH
INDIAN FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS HE
SAID THANK FIVE FIVE BECAUSE
HOLDING A LOT OF LEADERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY ACCOUNTABLE AND HE
BELIEVES THAT HOPE BRING THAT
EXPERIENCE OF WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH EACH A COMMUNITY. AND IN
MY EXPERIENCE MISSING FROM THE
AT&T BORDETELLA THANK YOU AND.
WE SUPPORT HIS NOMINATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU THERE
ARE NO FURTHER WITNESSES IN Q.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR WILL BE
BACK IN A MOMENT LET ME BRING
IT BACK INTO ROOM FOR TWO OH
THREE AND WE WILL SEE IF THERE
IS- IF THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE IN ROOM FOUR TWO OH THREE
LET ME MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEING NO ONE APPROACHING THE
DYESS IN ROOM ONE TWELVE MISTER
MODERATOR I'M COMING BACK TO
YOU FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WILL BE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU WE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONCE
AGAIN THOSE ARE CONSTRUCTIONS
ARE ONE AND. ZERO AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO SPEAKERS IN Q.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR LET ME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE TODAY WE
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP. SO ARE
BRINGING IT BACK TO MR MAJORITY
LEADER WHO IS WAITING TO MAKE
MOTION. SO MOVED THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CALL THE ROLL. FROM BATES.
HI IT'S I HERTZBERG HI IT'S
PROVIDE LAYERED HI THERE I WILK
HI LOOK I ATKINS ATKINS. FIVE
FIVE FIVE TWO ZERO FIVE TWO
ZERO CONGRATULATIONS AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
TODAY GOOD LUCK. THANK YOU
CHAIR VICE CHAIR MEMBERS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE. OKAY
COLLEAGUES ARE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF FOR
SOME REASON YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
OUR VISIT OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE COOPERATION I WANT TO
SAY WELCOME TO THE NEW MEMBERS
OF THE RULES COMMITTEE LET ME
FROM A DISTANCE THANK R.
STENOGRAPHER FINAL BLOCK WHO
CONTINUES TO SERVE US FROM A
DISTANCE. THANK ALL OF THE
STAFF AND WITH THAT- THE
JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH MEETING
OF THE RULES COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED.